Is your team winning? Yeah. Wait, but it's Sunday. I thought they played Saturday. It's Sunday. Yeah, they played both, innit? This is Liverpool that you're rooting for? Yeah, mate.
你的队伍赢了吗？赢了。等等，但今天是星期天。我以为他们星期六踢的。今天是星期天。对啊，他们两场都踢了，不是吗？这是你支持的利物浦队吗？对啊，老兄。
Yeah. Oh, fuck. Did they score a goal yet? Did they score a goal yet? Oh, hang on a second. We're doing a fold open, but we have a special surprise guest. Michael, do not turn around do not turn around there's Michael you're surrounded by a princess. There's a princess do you want to say hi? Yeah!
对。哦，操。他们进球了吗？他们进球了吗？哦，等一下。我们正在开场，但我们有一个特别的惊喜嘉宾。迈克尔，不要转身，不要转身，迈克尔就在那里，你被一个公主包围了。有个公主，你想打个招呼吗？想！
It's a tiny terry. Tiny terry. That was a tiny tiny terry and this is an all new uh smart smart. to Smartless. Smartless. What was that? Smartless. Smart. Lous. Smart. Lous.
是个小泰瑞。小泰瑞。那是个小小泰瑞，这是一个全新的，呃，聪明聪明的……致Smartless。Smartless。那是什么？Smartless。Smart。Lous。Smart。Lous。
Smart. Lous. Sean, I just did this stupid thing to Sean, but it reminded me before you came on, JB. The other day I keep finding new ways to embarrass Alessandro, we were at dinner, just the two of us over there in the Sag Harbor. And you forgot to wear your wig. No, and I, no.
Smart。Lous。肖恩，我刚才对肖恩做了这么一件蠢事，但它让我想起在你来之前，JB。前几天，我一直在寻找新的方式让亚历桑德罗难堪，我们在吃晚饭，就我们两个人在萨格港那边。而你忘带你的假发了。不，我，不。
How can you forget? The glue is so thick. And you keep it by the key bowl, right? Well, the glue's thick, the glue like. The key bowl. It says six weeks, but let's be honest, after five weeks it starts to crack. You have to reapply. Yeah glue like, it says six weeks, but let's be honest, after five weeks it starts to crack. You have to reapply.
你怎么能忘呢？胶水那么厚。而且你把它放在钥匙盘旁边，对吧？嗯，胶水很厚，胶水就像……钥匙盘。上面说六周，但老实说，五周后它就开始裂了。你得重新涂抹。对，胶水就像，上面说六周，但老实说，五周后它就开始裂了。你得重新涂抹。
Yeah, yeah, you're reapplying, but I have like a little caulking gun I can get under there sometimes. I can just do a touch up in the moment. You know what I mean? Like if I'm windsurfing. Get a good caulk, get a good caulk in there. But right as the, right as the,
对，对，你在重新涂抹，但我有时候能弄一把小嵌缝枪塞到下面。我随时都可以补涂一下。你知道我的意思吗？比如说我在玩帆板的时候。弄点好嵌缝，在里面弄点好嵌缝。但就在那个，就在那个……
as our server came to the table, I just go, I look up the server and go, one second. I go, oh sorry, so to answer your question, it's guess who's back backing it, Shady's back, tell a friend. As if I was going to ask her to ask me the lyrics to that Eminem song. And then I go, sorry, yeah, we're ready to order.
当我们的服务员来到桌边时，我直接说，我看着服务员说，等一下。我说，哦抱歉，所以回答你的问题，猜猜谁回来了，谢迪回来了，告诉朋友。好像我要请她问我阿姆那首歌的歌词一样。然后我说，抱歉，是的，我们准备点菜了。
Did the waiter have any idea? No idea. They're not there for entertainment. They're not psyched. They don't want to laugh at your stupid shit. Haven't you ever been? No, but you know like a waiter goes like, hey, we're all out of the salmon.
服务员有什么头绪吗？毫无头绪。他们不是去那儿娱乐的。他们才不兴奋。他们才不想笑话你的破事呢。你没去过吗？没有，但你知道，就像服务员走过来，嘿，我们三文鱼卖完了。
You go, all right, we're out of here. The waiter's like, hey, fucko. I've heard that a million times. I just want to take you fucking. But I've said it a bunch before, so apologies, but I have always kind of loved the idea of being a waiter just for the performative element of it where you have different, each table's a different stage,
你说，好吧，那我们走吧。服务员就像，嘿，混蛋。我听过一百万遍了。我只是想带你他妈的……但我以前说过很多次了，所以抱歉，但我一直有点喜欢当服务员的想法，仅仅是为了它的表演成分，每个桌子都是一个不同的舞台，
and you, different audience, and you got to figure out who they need you to be in order to get the biggest tip. Well, let's hope, let's Let's hope your new limited series hits, because if it doesn't, you might get a chance to try it out. Wait a minute, speaking of, black rabbit. Oh, Sean did the nicest thing last night. He came over last night with Scotty and took a look at the first two episodes,
而且你，不同的观众，你得弄清楚他们需要你成为谁，才能拿到最大笔的小费。好吧，让我们希望，让我们……让我们希望你的新迷你剧大火，因为如果不火的话，你可能就有机会去尝试一下了。等一下，说到这个，黑兔。哦，肖恩昨晚做了最棒的事。他昨晚带着斯科特过来，看了前两集，
because we're not locked yet, I need eyes on it, I need opinions. And you're gonna shut your mouth for one second, because, Will, have you seen the two episodes, because we're not locked yet, I need eyes on it, I need opinions. And you're going to shut your mouth for one second, because, Will, have you seen the two episodes, the first two episodes? Well, no, I'm not there with you. No, I didn't know if you could send it to him. It's so fucking great.
因为我们还没定剪，我需要有人过目，我需要意见。而你要把你的嘴闭上一秒钟，因为，维尔，你看过那两集吗，因为我们还没定剪，我需要有人过目，我需要意见。而你要把你的嘴闭上一秒钟，因为，维尔，你看过那两集吗，前两集？嗯，没有，我没跟你在一起。不，我不知道你能不能发给他。太他妈棒了。
What are you going to say? It's so good. Of course you're going to say it. He doesn't need to go out on a little bit of a serious. I'd be like, oh, it's really good, anyway, well, that's good. It's so good, and Jay, that character is unlike anything I've ever seen you play before. It's so surprising and exciting.
你要说什么？太棒了。你当然会这么说。他不需要表现得有点严肃。我会觉得，哦，真的很棒，总之，嗯，挺好的。太棒了，杰，那个角色跟你以前演过的任何角色都不同。太令人惊奇和兴奋了。
And- So it's likable. Yeah. No, but, and it's going to be one of those series everybody talks about. Of course it is. You're completely sucked in right away. Who's that?
而且——所以它很讨人喜欢。对。不，但是，这会成为那种每个人都在谈论的剧集。当然会。你一下子就被完全吸引进去了。那是谁？
Why is that guy? And you start asking your questions as an audience member and you know they're going to get answered in the few episodes that follow, but it's so exciting. When you didn't run after the first episode, I knew I was in good shape, because you do like to be in bed 530. JB, you must feel good,
那家伙是谁？然后作为观众，你开始问各种问题，你知道它们会在接下来的几集里得到解答，但它太令人兴奋了。当你第一集播完后没有逃跑时，我就知道我状态不错，因为你确实喜欢5点30分就上床睡觉。JB，你一定感觉很好，
and you've got to get a bunch of demographics, you know, you've got the moron demographic that I was covered, they're in. I was really pressing him and Scottie, I was like, you guys sure you understood everything? He asked me that after. He asked me that after. You sure you understood everything?
而且你得吸引一群不同的人群，你知道，你搞定了那个笨蛋群体，他们入坑了。我当时真的在逼问他和斯科特，我问，你们俩确定看懂所有内容了吗？他事后问我那个。他事后问我那个。你确定看懂所有内容了吗？
I bet it's gonna be great. I have no doubt. And JB, I'm gonna say this too while we're in this vein. I was thinking about the breadth of stuff that you've done. I was thinking about the last couple years. I was thinking about a movie that I love that doesn't get enough attention. Which. Air Bud 2? No, no, no, no, no, Game Night. Game Night? a movie that I love that doesn't get enough attention, which-
我敢打赌这一定会很棒。毫无疑问。而且JB，趁着这个话头，我也要说这个。我一直在想你做过的那些事情的广度。我一直在想过去几年。我一直在想一部我喜欢的、但没有得到足够关注的电影。哪部。
AirBud 2? No, no, no, no, Game Night. Game Night, guys, so great. Game Night, which I think is so funny, so good. And then you do like Identity Thief, then you do Ozark. You've done so many different things. And hats off to you, you don't get enough credit. You do a lot of great shit, so congrats.
空中飞狗2？不，不，不，不，不，游戏之夜。游戏之夜？一部我喜欢的、但没有得到足够关注的电影，哪个——空中飞狗2？不，不，不，不，游戏之夜。游戏之夜，伙计们，太棒了。游戏之夜，我觉得超级搞笑，超级棒。然后你演了身份贼，然后你演了黑钱胜地。你演了太多不同的角色了。向你致敬，你得到的认可还不够。你拍了很多棒极了的烂片，所以恭喜。
And I'm excited for Black Rabbit. And the reason I bring it up is because you've been working so fucking hard, I know I exhausted you, but you've excited for Black Rabbit. And the reason I bring it up is because you've been working so fucking hard. I know I exhausted you, but you've been fucking doing it. And it's very inspiring. I really appreciate that. Listener, I apologize for all of this. No, no.
我很期待《黑兔》。我提起这个是因为你工作太他妈努力了，我知道我把你累坏了，但你很期待《黑兔》。我提起这个是因为你工作太他妈努力了。我知道我把你累坏了，但你他妈的一直在做。这非常鼓舞人心。我真的很感激。听众们，为这一切向你们道歉。不，不。
We're going to pay it back in spades. Having said that. I know, I should go on. Couple thoughts. Keep your email open, Jay. I got some thoughts. Oh my God. I was sort of, not to throw back the wind, Keep your email open, Jay, I got some problems.
我们会加倍奉还的。话虽如此。我知道，我该继续了。几个想法。把你的邮箱开着，杰。我有一些想法。哦，天哪。我有点，不是要把风……把你的邮箱开着，杰，我有一些问题。
I was sort of, not to throw back the wind, up the bum, but I was thinking for some reason this morning, oh I know why, because our next guest is a fancy pants in the Tony world, that Sean, you want a fucking Tony. Okay, no. No, no, no, but I mean, that's like, we did spend a little time on that, but it does keep coming back to me. That's not something they hand out, you know? It's a Tony is a real deal.
我有点，不是要把风吹回屁股里去，但我今天早上不知道为什么在想，哦，我知道为什么，因为我们的下一个嘉宾是托尼奖世界里的时尚大咖，肖恩，你赢得了他妈的托尼奖。好吧，不。不，不，不，但我的意思是，这就好像，我们确实在这上面花了一点时间，但它确实一直回到我脑海里。那可不是他们随便颁发的东西，你知道吗？托尼奖是来真的。
Believe me, it's not lost on me. It's like, that's a whole different community that I just, I'm very, very proud of you on this. You both will do it, you both will do it, and you'll both be nominated, and you'll both win. Yeah, I doubt it, but we may try. It is pretty amazing. I was even about to do handout to a Tony and Sean
相信我，我心里有数。这就好比，那是另一个圈子，对此我真的、真的很为你骄傲。你们俩都会做到的，你们俩都会做到的，你们俩都会被提名，你们俩都会获奖。是的，我表示怀疑，但这或许可以尝试。这真是太棒了。我甚至差点要向托尼奖和肖恩颁奖了，
in Handy from a Tony, but I didn't. I'm like, fuck it, I'm not gonna do that because I respect you too much and I love you too much. And I'm not gonna make a stupid joke and try to connect. It's too easy. It's too easy and it's too thin, you know? What else can we talk about while our listener or listener and guest.
从托尼奖那里亲手颁发，但我没有。我想，操的，我才不干那事呢，因为我太尊重你了，我太爱你了。我才不会开个蠢玩笑去硬套关系呢。太容易了。太容易了，也太肤浅了，你知道吗？在我们的听众或听众和嘉宾在场时，我们还能聊点别的什么。
I got a couple things, but we should probably get to it. Go off the list, open up the list. No, I was just gonna say on the way home, I told Will, Will, you and I were driving home from a friend's house we visited in the hills a couple months ago. And I told Will the story, but Jay, I haven't told you. So when you go past Greystone Mansion,
我有几件事要说，但我们可能得进入正题了。抛开清单，打开清单。不，我只是想说，在回家的路上，我告诉了维尔，维尔，几个月前，你和我从山上一位朋友家做客回来，我们在开车回家。我把这个故事告诉了维尔，但杰，我还没告诉你。所以当你开过格雷斯通大厦时，
and there's a runaway ramp there, right? And one lot of gravel. So like several years ago, I was like, oh, let's try that. Yes, I did. I swear to God, I tried it. Because I was like, what would it feel like? Because I want to know what it felt like. Well, I didn try that. Yes, I did. Come on. I swear to God I tried it. You stupid ass. Because I was like, what would it feel like? Because I want to know what it felt like.
那里有一个紧急逃生车道，对吧？还有一堆碎石。所以几年前，我当时想，哦，我们试试那个吧。是的，我试过。我发誓，我试过了。因为我想，那会是什么感觉？因为我想知道那是什么感觉。好吧，我没有试过那个。是的，我试过。少来。我发誓我试过了。你这个大笨蛋。因为我想，那会是什么感觉？因为我想知道那是什么感觉。
Well, I didn't know it was, I thought it was just like an inch of gravel. It was just to stop a truck. But it's like 80 feet of gravel. So when I drove up it. To stop a truck. Yeah. It's supposed to completely absorb you like quicksand.
好吧，我不知道那是，我以为那只有一英寸厚的碎石。那只是用来拦住卡车的。但那里有大约80英尺厚的碎石。所以当我把车开上去的时候。拦住卡车。对。它本该像流沙一样完全将你吞没。
I drove up it and I, God damn it, you're doing it. I know and I started singing. I was like, holy shit, I got so scared. I peeled it out, I kicked some gravel up, and thank God I got out of there. You got out? Yeah.
我把车开上去，我，操你的，你在学我。我知道，然后我开始唱歌。我当时想，卧槽，我吓坏了。我猛打方向掉头，溅起了一些碎石，谢天谢地我从那儿逃出来了。你逃出来了？对。
What car were you in, your Audi? No, it was before that. Oh my God, you're so lucky you weren't the dumb ass next to a call in a tow truck. Like quicksand. And just like with your hands up, like had to try it, sorry. I would have loved to have seen that, to open up the Daily Mail and see pictures of you
你开的什么车，你的奥迪？不，那是之前的事了。哦，天哪，你太幸运了，没有成为那个站在拖车旁边的蠢货，就像流沙一样。就像把手举起来，像不得不试一下一样，抱歉。我当时很想看到那一幕，打开《每日邮报》看到你的照片，
next to the tow truck and just explaining to the cop and then you have to pay because they had to come over. All right, here we come. Guest, wake it up. Listener, pull the car over. Our next guest is one of my favorite people in the world, period. Wow.
站在拖车旁边，向警察解释，然后你还得付钱，因为他们不得不赶过来。好了，我们来吧。嘉宾，醒醒。听众，把车靠边停下。我们的下一嘉宾是我在世界上最喜欢的人之一，绝对的。哇。
There are some people that you meet, have a connection, you become friends, the connection grows, carries through many years, many stages of your life, and theirs. These people become your family. There aren't many in our lives, so when you have one, you smile and bounce a little every moment you spend with them.
有些人你遇到了，产生了某种联系，你们成了朋友，这种联系不断加深，贯穿了许多年，贯穿了你和他们生命的许多阶段。这些人成了你的家人。我们生命中这样的人不多，所以当你有这样一个人的时候，你每和他们度过一刻，都会微笑并且高兴得有点蹦蹦跳跳。
And if you're lucky enough to work with one of these people, you end up doing a lot of smiling. So between you guys and her, my cheeks are killing me. She's one of our finest actors, an accomplished producer, a rising director, an incredible mother, wife and daughter. She's the recipient of three Academy Award nominations, five Tonys, nine SAGs, won one of those, a BAFTA, eight Golden Globes, won two of those,
如果你有幸与其中一位合作，最后你会笑得合不拢嘴。所以托你们和她的福，我的脸颊都快笑僵了。她是她那一辈最优秀的演员之一，一位出色的制片人，一位冉冉升起的新星导演，一位不可思议的母亲、妻子和女儿。她曾获得三次奥斯卡奖提名、五次托尼奖提名、九次演员工会奖提名（并赢得了其中一次）、一个英国电影学院奖、八次金球奖提名（赢得了其中两次），
and seven Emmy nominations, won four of those. She also has a doctorate from Brown and Juilliard guys, please welcome my fake wife, but true bestie Laura Linney And a dead dog in the background Long time coming And you had to suffer through all that bullshit we were talking about. I had to earn my place. I thought that maybe you and Jason were in a fight. It's been so long.
如果你有幸能和这样的人一起工作，你最后会笑个不停。所以介于你们俩和她之间，我的脸颊都要笑僵了。她是我们最优秀的演员之一、一位出色的制片人、一位崛起的导演、一位不可思议的母亲、妻子和女儿。她曾获得三次奥斯卡奖提名、五个托尼奖、九个演员工会奖，赢得过其中一个，一个英国电影学院奖，八个金球奖，赢得过其中两个，
I thought, what happened? She's tough to schedule, you know? She's busy and her deal is a tough deal. Sure. I'm thrilled to be here. It's great to see all of you. You too. I mean, when he was going through all of those noms,. Well, I'm thrilled to be here. It's great to see all of you.
我想，这是怎么回事？她的档期很难约，你知道的？她很忙，而且她的片酬要求也很高。当然。我很高兴能来到这里。很高兴见到大家。我也是。我是说，当他历数那些提名时……好吧，我很高兴能来到这里。很高兴见到大家。
You too. I mean, when he was going through all of those noms, like nine, I mean, five Academy, I mean, it's unbelievable. People like her. It's bonkers. She doesn't suck. Laura, I'm going to say this. Would you ever think about getting a t-shirt made
我也是。我是说，当他历数那些提名时，比如九个，我的意思是，五个学院奖，我的天，这太难以置信了。人们喜欢她。这太疯狂了。她可真不赖。劳拉，我想说的是。你有没有想过定制一件T恤，
that had listed all your nominations? You just wear it. Front and back. That just says, ask me about the seven Academy Awards, the baffled. The thing about it is every once in a while, I mean, I don't know if you guys like this, but I have to stop and every once in a while,
上面印满你所有的提名？然后你就穿着它。前后都印上。上面只写着：“来问问我关于那七次奥斯卡奖和那个得奖的事吧。”最神奇的是，每隔一段时间——我不知道你们是不是也这样，但我不得不停下来，每隔一段时间，
it'll hit me and I'll have to remind myself, because you never feel like that's happened. I mean, you never, you know, and I've been nominated a lot and I don't win all that much, but I'm nominated a lot. But every once in a while, I'll be walking down the street and it will hit me, I'll be like, oh my God. Oh my God, like Sean, like Tony winner.
这感觉就会涌上心头，我不得不提醒自己，因为你从来不觉得自己真的经历过那些。我是说，你从不——你知道的，虽然我获得过很多提名，而且我也不是每次都能拿奖，但我确实拿过很多提名。不过每隔一段时间，当我走在街上时，这种感觉就会突然袭来，我会想，哦天哪。哦天哪，就像肖恩那样，托尼奖得主。
Tony winner, it's amazing, congratulations. In a soft year, but Laura, I think the thing that keeps us all sort of grounded is, and I'm looking at, again, pointing out that your dog is asleep in the background of your shot, no matter what you do, how many nominations, no matter how accomplished somebody is, they're always likely in a room where there's a dog that's asleep and doesn't give a shit.
托尼奖得主，这太棒了，恭喜。虽然是在一个竞争不激烈的年份，但劳拉，我觉得能让我们所有人保持脚踏实地的是——我又看了看，再次指出，你的狗正睡在你画面的背景里。无论你做什么，获得多少提名，无论一个人取得多大的成就，他们很可能总是身处于这样一个房间里：里面有一只正在呼呼大睡、根本不在乎这一切的狗。
Do you know what I mean? Yeah, and the sock drawer's a mess, and there's stuff that hasn't been taken care of, and I'm behind on everything, and I have family members who are peeped at me because they haven't heard from me in so long. And so there's all of that stuff, absolutely. But then there is the wild moment where you're like,
你知道我的意思吗？对，而且袜抽屉一团糟，还有一堆没处理好的事情，我什么事都落后了，而且我还有一些家人生我的气，因为我已经很久没联系他们了。所以所有这些琐事都是真实的，绝对的。但随后就会出现那种狂喜的时刻，你会觉得：
oh my God, I cannot believe my life has led me here. I cannot believe I've been able to do everything I've been able to do. Yes, and that you, the thing that you chose to do with your life actually paid off in spades. Oh my God. Yeah. Come on, crazy.
哦天哪，我简直不敢相信我的人生竟然把我带到了这里。我简直不敢相信我能做到所有这些我做过的事。是的，而且你——你这一生选择做的事情真的得到了最丰厚的回报。哦天哪。是的。得了吧，太疯狂了。
What about what a great writer you are too. I'll bet you've got some, you've won plenty of things, but you've been nominated a shit ton too. So I'll bet there've won plenty of things, but you've been nominated a shit ton too. So I'll bet there's some speeches. Now do you keep them in a drawer? Do you remember them? Because I want to have like a coffee table book once of all the unused speeches
话说回来，你也是个多么优秀的作家啊。我敢说你肯定也……你赢过很多奖，但也获得过海量的提名。所以我敢说你肯定也……你赢过很多奖，但也获得过海量的提名。所以我敢说肯定有很多获奖感言。现在，你把它们收在抽屉里吗？你还记得它们吗？因为我想搞一本类似于咖啡桌读物的书，收录所有那些没机会发表的获奖感言，
and whether it would be anonymous or not. Wouldn't that be great? Yes. The thing that I found is that you sort of, you have a sense if you're in the running to win. And then there are times when you're like, I'm not winning, there's no way I'm going to win. So in some ways that's the nicest,
不管是匿名的还是署名的。那不是很棒吗？是的。我发现的一点是，你大概、你会有种直觉，自己到底在不在获胜的热门人选里。然后有时你会想：我不会赢的，我绝对不可能赢。所以在某种程度上，那反而是最轻松的，
because then you go and you get to have a good time and you're nominated, but you know you're not going to win. So you don't have to worry about, I'm going to forget, nothing prepared, because I know. Oh my God, it's so scary. And then there are the times when you know you're in the running for things, and you do have to prepare.
因为那样的话你就可以去享受一段美好的时光，你获得了提名，但你知道自己不会赢。所以你不需要担心：我会忘词吗？有没有准备？因为我心知肚明。哦天哪，这太吓人了。但有时你知道自己确实在获奖的有力竞争者之列，你就必须做好准备。
So I must admit, I do have a few. Well, Laura, would it be interesting to go back and look at some of those unused acceptance speeches and go like, oh, I was going to thank that person. Not today. Not today. Not today, I wouldn't. It's like going over your will.
所以我必须承认，我确实保留了一些。好吧，劳拉，回过头去看看那些没用上的获奖感言，然后感叹一句“哦，我本来打算感谢那个人的”，这会有趣吗？今天可不行。今天不行。今天可不行，我才不看。这就好像在审视你的遗嘱。
It's going to shift. You're out of the will. The winds have changed. So all of which is to say, as I did say, you don't suck. You're great at what you do. And it started a long time ago. Tell us about, remember the first thing you saw or were exposed to that made you think,
它会变动的。你被从遗嘱里除名了。风向已经变了。所以，总而言之，正如我刚才所说，你真的很棒。你对自己的工作驾轻就熟。这一切开始于很久以前。跟我们聊聊吧，还记得你看到的第一部或是让你接触到的第一部作品是什么，让你心想：
oh, I think I'd like to see if I could maybe do that. Was it a show, was it a movie, was it a play? It was the original production of Vanities that was downtown at St. Clement's Theater. How old were you? In the church. I was, well, my father was a playwright, so I grew up around the theater.
哦，我想我大概也想看看自己能不能做这个。那是一个节目、一部电影，还是一部戏剧？那是外百老汇圣克莱门斯剧院上演的原版《虚荣》（Vanities）。你当时多大？在教堂里。我当时……好吧，我父亲是个剧作家，所以我是在剧院周围长大的。
So I always knew I wanted to be a part of it in some way. I really didn't think I'd be an actress. It took me a long time to sort of get there, but I went and saw this play, and Kathy Bates was in it. No way. Yeah. It's a three-person play. It's not the greatest work of dramatic literature
所以我一直都知道自己想以某种方式参与其中。我其实并没有想过自己会成为一名演员。我花了很长的时间才走到这一步，但当时我去看了这部戏，凯西·贝茨（Kathy Bates）也在里面。不会吧。是的。这是一部三个人的戏。它可能不是最伟大的戏剧文学作品，
ever written, but there was something about it and being in that space and watching those three women be so wonderful. And I remember leaving, I was like, oh, I'm different. Something has changed. And it's the power of really good work. You know? Teenager?
但也说不上史上最佳，但它就是有一种魔力，身处那个空间里，看着那三个女人表现得如此出色。我记得离开时，我在想：哦，我变了。有什么东西改变了。这就是真正优秀作品的力量。你知道吗？青少年？
Oh no, I was younger, definitely younger. Yeah? Yeah, I think I was 11 or 12, probably. Wow, yeah. Wow, that's really cool. All right, so then from there, do you say to your dad, hey, what do you think the best first steps might be for me to go in this direction?
哦不，我当时更小，绝对更小。是吗？对，我想我大概11或12岁吧。哇，真的。哇，这真的很酷。好吧，那么从那以后，你有没有对你爸爸说：“嘿，你觉得对我来说，朝这个方向发展迈出的第一步最好是什么？”
Or how did that start? What happened was my father was an apprentice at a theater in New London, New Hampshire called the Barn Playhouse. The New London Barn Playhouse. And I used to spend the summers with my dad. My parents split when I was very young, so I would spend time with my dad during the summers, and I begged him to let me go work there, begged him.
或者这一切是怎么开始的？情况是这样的：我父亲是新罕布什尔州新伦敦一家名为“谷仓剧场”（Barn Playhouse）的剧院的学徒。新伦敦谷仓剧院。我过去常常和爸爸一起度过夏天。我父母在我很小的时候就分开了，所以我夏天会和爸爸在一起，我求他让我去那里工作，死缠烂打地求他。
So I went and I was a technical apprentice. And I broke every child labor law known to me. I was there for like 14, oh yeah, making a mess and doing all sorts of stuff and being way too young to be doing what I was there for like 14, oh yeah, you know, making a mess and doing all sorts of stuff and being way too young to be doing what I was doing. But it was- Sleeping drunk in the dressing room. Like seeing everybody hook up and break up.
于是我去了，成了一名技术学徒。我违反了我所知道的所有童工法。我在那儿待了大概14个小时，哦对，把事情搞得一团糟，做着各种各样的事，年龄太小根本不该干我当时在做的事……等等，我在那儿待了大概14个小时，哦对，你知道的，把事情搞得一团糟，做着各种各样的事，年龄太小根本不该干我当时在做的事。但那是——在化妆室里喝醉睡觉。就像看所有人勾搭和分手。
You're refereeing a lot of hookups. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. But then what about the first time you got on stage and like risked, you know, look at me, let's see if I got it. Yeah, it was a production of, it was a Christmas show at school. Uh-huh.
你还得调解很多场恋情。对，对，绝对是的。但话说回来，你第一次上台并冒险尝试，你知道的，“看着我，看看我行不行”是什么时候？是的，那是学校的一场演出，一个圣诞节目。嗯哼。
How, wait, which school, how old? I was, I was really young, it was middle school, and it was the same year that Ms. Magazine came out. Ah. So we did. Oh, that was 1981. Sorry. That's right, that's right. We did a Oh, that was 1981. Sorry. That's right, that's right. We did a feminist turn. We did a feminist turn on Santa Claus
怎么，等等，哪个学校，多大年纪？我当时、我真的很小，那是初中，而且正好是《女士》杂志（Ms. Magazine）创刊的那一年。啊。所以我们排演了。哦，那是1981年。抱歉。没错，就是这样。我们排演了一部——哦，那是1981年。抱歉。没错，就是这样。我们排演了一部带有女权主义色彩的《圣诞老人》剧目，
where Santa got a cold and Mrs. Claus had to take over. So it was that. Oh, nice. I remember one of the first things I ever saw that made me go, wow, I was like 12 years old and I saw a chorus line. And I always thought how different my life would be if I'd only seen it sooner, like at five, six, seven, eight.
讲的是圣诞老人得了感冒，圣诞老人太太不得不接替他的工作。就是这个。哦，真棒。我还记得我看到的第一部让我惊叹不已的作品，我当时大约12岁，我看了《歌舞线上》（A Chorus Line）。我总是在想，如果我能早点看到它，比如在5岁、6岁、7岁、8岁的时候，我的人生会有多大不同。
Anyway, go ahead, sorry. Five, six, seven, eight, is that what? Yeah, yeah, yeah. So then, all right, now we get, you start going, you start building up some momentum, and then you end up, you end up, now does Brown really kind of formalize your leap into this world, or was it at Julliard? I, well, I think probably, at Brown I was more
总之，你继续，抱歉。5、6、7、8，是这样吗？对，对，对。所以接下来，好吧，我们说到这儿，你开始出发，你开始积聚一些势头，然后你最终，你最终——现在，布朗大学真的算是正式开启了你迈向这个世界的飞跃吗？还是在茱莉亚学院？我，好吧，我想可能在布朗大学时，我更多是
sort of an academic theater nerd, so I studied theater history and all that sort of fun stuff and then Julliard was where it got serious, yeah. And the first sort of job that exposed you to the world would be? I was the understudy in a production of Six Degrees of Separation, which was right across the street at Lincoln Center.
那种学院派的戏剧书呆子，所以我研究了戏剧史和所有那些有趣的东西，然后茱莉亚学院才是让我真正开始认真对待的地方，是的。那么让你初露头角、接触到这个圈子的第一份工作是？我是林肯中心街对面正在上演的《六度分离》（Six Degrees of Separation）剧组的候补演员。
Oh wow. And I was actually at that theater yesterday watching Holland Taylor in NA. So it was fun. Every time I go in that space, it's professionally where I started. So I was the happiest understudy around. There was this room of understudies who were like,
哦，真的。我昨天其实还去那个剧院看霍兰·泰勒（Holland Taylor）演的《NA》呢。所以这很有趣。每次我走进那个空间，我都觉得那是我的职业起点。所以我是周围最快乐的候补演员。当时有一个候补演员休息室，里面的人都在说：
hello, yeah, hey kid, how you doing? They've been understudies for years. And I would bounce in happy as can be. And I would sit in the catwalk and watch the show. That's up top, that's overlooking, yeah. Yeah, where the lights are. And I would sneak up there and watch, just to watch Stockard Channing get better and better
嗨，太好了，嘿，孩子，最近怎么样？他们当候补演员已经好多年了。而我总是快快乐乐地蹦蹦跳跳。我会坐在猫道（高空工作桥）上观看演出。那是顶部，可以俯瞰全场，对。对，就是挂灯光的地方。我会偷偷溜到那里去观看，就为了看斯托卡德·钱宁（Stockard Channing）的表现越来越好、
and better and better and better. And there was one night, I remember, Katharine Hepburn came to see the show. And I was in the catwalk watching Katharine Hepburn watch Stockard Channing. Wow. And you're by yourself or you with somebody else? There's somebody in the catwalk. I think they haven't got it.
越来越好、越来越好、越来越好、越来越好。我还记得有一天晚上，凯瑟琳·赫本（Katharine Hepburn）来看演出。而我就在猫道上看着凯瑟琳·赫本看着斯托卡德·钱宁。哇。你是自己一个人，还是和别人一起？猫道上还有别人。我想他们没去。
Wait, Laura, I've never heard that before. That you're up by yourself, up by the catwalk at Lincoln Center at what, a teenager, young? No, no, no, this was after Juilliard. So I was early, mid-20s. Yeah, oh my God. And because I had done stock
等等，劳拉，我以前从没听过这个。你一个人待在林肯中心的猫道上，当时大概几岁，十几岁，还是年轻的时候？不，不，不，这是在茱莉亚学院毕业之后。所以我大概二十岁出头。天哪，真的。而且因为我做过夏季剧场
and was a technical apprentice, I knew how to get up into the catwalk. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And you got a little snack with you, a little. No, you just sit and you just watch. Yes, in high school I used to hang out up there. Yeah, it's no fun. But when there's no show, we would just go up there
和技术学徒，我知道怎么爬到猫道上去。对，对，对。你还带了点心上去吗？没有，你就在那儿坐着看。是的，我在高中时就经常在那上面闲逛。对，这可真没劲。不过在没有演出的时候，我们就会去那上面，
and like, class and whatever. Except Sean did have a snack with him, right? What was his snack, Sean? Probably, it was probably Swedish fish. But Laura, it occurs to me that you were so, you had no choice but to do this life that you chose or it chose you. A little bit, yeah.
上课或者干别的。不过肖恩确实带了点心对吧？他带了什么点心，肖恩？大概，可能是一包瑞典小鱼软糖吧。不过劳拉，我突然觉得，你当时真的是别无选择，只能走上你选择的这条生活道路，或者说，是它选择了你。某种程度上是这样的，对。
Because it was at such a young age and it was just, that was your life. You were around, you were in summer stock, you were the thing, your dad, you know, it was all around you. You wouldn't know. Thank God it worked out. And thank God I love it as much as I do.
因为你当时太年轻了，那就是你的生活。你就在剧院周围，你在夏季剧场，做着那些事，你父亲……你知道的，这一切环绕着你。你根本无从知晓。谢天谢地，一切都顺利。也谢天谢地，我依然像当初一样热爱它。
Yeah. Do you still love it as much as I do? I love it. I love it. More now or less? Oh, I think more. Because the longer I'm in it, like a new set of problems sort of unlock themselves.
对。你现在还像以前一样热爱它吗？我很爱。我太爱了。现在是更爱了还是变少了？哦，我觉得更爱了。因为我在这一行待得越久，就像解锁了一套全新的问题。
It's like I've earned the right to a new set of problems. And so it just keeps going. And talk about the eight shows a week thing. You still enjoy that. Yeah, hi. I do. But how insane is that? No one has any idea what that is.
就好像我已经赢得了去面对一套新问题的资格。所以这一切还在继续。聊聊一周八场演出这事吧。你现在还享受这个吗？对，嗨。我很享受。但那有多疯狂？没有人知道那到底是什么体验。
The most difficult job in the world. Unbelievable. And that type of fatigue is a very specific fatigue. Well, plus in the one woman shows you've been doing too. Like that's like massagist. That was bonkers. Why did I do that? Nowhere to hide in a one woman show, right?
世界上最难的工作。难以置信。而且那种疲惫感是一种非常特殊的疲惫。对了，还有你演过的那些独角戏。那种感觉简直像是在受虐。那太疯狂了。我当时为什么要接那部戏？独角戏里根本无处可藏，对吧？
I know. And I did it three times. I don't, you know. Wow. I did it once in London. This was a show called My Name is Lucy Barton. And then I did it again in London to see if it would called My Name is Lucy Barton, and then I did it again in London to see if it would get easier,
我知道。而且我演了三次。我真不知道……（笑）哇。我在伦敦演过一次。那是一部叫《我的名字叫露西·巴顿》（My Name is Lucy Barton）的戏。后来我又在伦敦演了一次，看看会不会叫《我的名字叫露西·巴顿》，然后我又在伦敦演了一次，看看会不会
because my first run wasn't that long. I was like, well if it comes to New York, will it get easier? And what I learned is no, it does not get easier. It does not get easier. If anything it gets harder, yeah. Yeah, yeah. So you get all this incredible training at Juilliard,
变得轻松一点，因为我的第一轮演出没那么长。我想，好吧，如果它巡演到纽约，会不会变得更容易呢？而我学到的教训是：不，一点也没有变容易。它并没有变容易。如果要说有什么不同的话，那就是变得更难了，是的。对，对。所以你在茱莉亚学院接受了所有这些不可思议的训练，
and then you come out into, let's say, showbiz. What were the biggest challenges coming out of that and into this? Into a professional situation you mean? Yeah, several. That's less sort of protected in sort of this, you know, theater world and technique and study and culture and entering more of sort of a business.
然后你踏入，比方说，演艺圈。从那样一个环境出来，进入这个圈子，最大的挑战是什么？你是说进入一个职业环境吗？对，有好几个。比起那种在戏剧世界、技术、学习和文化中受到较多保护的环境，这里更像是一个商业社会。
Well, you have to learn how to translate what you've learned into an appropriate setting. You mean camera versus stage? Well, there's that, but then also just on stage. I mean, there's like, going to school is very different than being in the profession. And going to school, there's a certain type of concentration and there's a certain ability to get things done
嗯，你必须学会如何将你所学的东西转化到一个合适的语境中。你是说镜头表演和舞台表演的区别？嗯，有这方面的原因，但不仅仅是镜头和舞台，在舞台上也是如此。我是说，去上学和从事这个职业是完全两码事。在学校里，有一种特定类型的专注力，也有一种把事情做好的能力，
and you have to learn how to translate that so you're still doing what you're doing but that it's appropriate for the situation that you're in. No one wants to hear about your process when they're working. Right, right. No one wants to hear about it. Actually, Will. You got to zip it. You have to deliver.
而你必须学会如何转化这些，好让你依然在做你该做的事，同时又能适应你所处的环境。当大家都在工作时，没有人想听你大谈你的“创作心路历程”。对，对。没人想听这些。实际上，威尔。你得闭嘴。你必须拿出成果。
Will loves that, actually. You got to, I remember, because I did it with him on Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles. We did that so many times. I know, we sure did. We did a lot of processing there. We did a lot of processing there. We sure did.
威尔其实挺喜欢这个的。你得——我记得，因为我和他一起拍过《忍者神龟：变种时代》。我们排练时不知搞了多少次。我知道，我们当然有。我们在那上面做了大量的心理剖析。我们在那上面做了大量的心理剖析。我们确实这么干过。
Which a lot of, you know, decisions, choices. How would a turtle walk? That's right. Yeah, I think that turtle's going too fast, realistically. But what about, how about like going away from the sort of, going into much more of a world of, now I gotta make a living doing this. How do those two things reconcile?
里面包含了很多，你知道的，决定、选择。乌龟会怎么走路？没错。对，我觉得那只乌龟走得太快了，从现实角度来看。但是，怎么说呢，抛开那些，进入一个“我必须靠这个谋生”的世界，这两者是怎么调和的？
You know, you just sort of throw yourself in it and you just hope to God it's gonna be okay. Right. And you wait tables. Yeah. And you just sort of keep at it. And you realize. That's what Jason wants to do.
你知道的，你只能一头扎进去，然后祈祷一切都会好起来。对。然后你还得去端盘子。对。然后你就咬牙坚持下去。然后你意识到。杰森想去干这个。
That's right. I wouldn't be bad. I don't think I'd be, were you any good as a waiter? You wouldn't be good at it because you'd have to touch things. You'd have to touch other people's food and that would not go terribly well for you, I don't think. Trust people who know you, you'd be awful at it. I could deliver the food,
没错。我也不会差到哪去。我觉得我不会——你当服务员能行吗？你肯定干不好，因为你得接触各种东西。你得碰别人的食物，我觉得这事对你来说可不会太顺利。相信了解你的人吧，你在这方面肯定一塌糊涂。我可以把食物端过去，
I don't think I could clean up afterwards. You know, like when they take the utensils and they gather them in the middle of the plate. No, you'd have to touch them, you'd have to do that. I'd be so gloved up. Yeah, no, I don't think so. We'll be right back. build the plates. I would have to touch them. You'd have to do that. I'd be so gloved up. I don't think so. We'll be right back.
我觉得我没法清理残羹剩饭。你知道的，就像他们把餐具收起来堆在盘子中间那样。不，你得去碰它们，你必须做这些。我会戴满手套的。对，不，我可不觉得。我们马上回来。把盘子收好。我得去碰它们。你必须做这些。我会戴满手套的。我可不觉得。我们马上回来。
All right, back to the show. I have to ask you, Laura, I was gonna wait till the end, but I'm gonna ask you now. Any great theater stories? Yes, not just that. I guess. Like something, you must have like a classic something that went horribly wrong. Oh Lord.
好的，欢迎回到节目中。我得问你个问题，劳拉，本来想留到最后的，但我现在就想问。有什么精彩的剧院趣事吗？有，不仅仅是那个。我想是的。比如有什么，你肯定经历过那种糟糕透顶的经典囧事吧。天哪。
You can come back to it too. Yeah, we can come back to it. Because he wants a good one. I love them. They're the funniest stories. They are the funniest stories. Because so much funny shit happens. Didn't somebody have a heart attack
你也可以待会儿再说。对，我们可以待会儿再说。因为他想听个好故事。我很爱听。那些都是最好笑的故事。它们确实是最好笑的故事。因为总会发生那么多滑稽的破事。难道没人
while they were doing a show once? Yeah, who was that? One of our guests, who was that? No, they didn't. No, they didn't, but somebody in the audience did. Yeah. Yeah, it's usually, the good stories usually happen when you're in a show that's really bad.
在演戏的时候突发心脏病吗？对，那是谁？我们的嘉宾里，那是谁？不，没有。不，他们没有，但观众席里有人突发心脏病了。对。对，通常，好故事往往发生在你参演了一部真的很烂的戏的时候。
Yeah. I mean, really bad, of which I've been in several. And it's so painful, and you really think you're going to rip the skin off your body just to get out of the embarrassment and the humiliation of it. What about Laura, is there any show that you did that you, and by show I mean any kind of a stage show that you did,
对。我是说，真的烂透了的戏，而我演过好几部。那种感觉太痛苦了，你真觉得你想把身上的皮撕下来，好逃离那种尴尬和羞辱。劳拉，有没有哪部戏是你演过的——这里说的“戏”指任何类型的舞台演出——虽然不想让任何人难堪，但你当时以为这会大火，结果观众却完全不买账？你心里其实是有数的。
and not to make anybody feel bad, but you thought this is gonna be the thing and it just didn't click with audiences. You sort of know. Oh, yeah, yeah. You kind of know if it's really bad. You kind of know. It's the ones where you think like,
哦，对，对。如果真的很烂，你心里多少是有数的。你心里是有数的。就是那种你觉得：
oh, this is right on the edge. I don't know. I don't think this is terrible. I think it's pretty good. I don't know how good it is. You never know how good it is. Yeah. Right. But you know how bad it is.
哦，这简直是在走钢丝。我不知道。我觉得这不至于太糟糕。我觉得还挺不错的。我不知道它到底有多好。你永远不知道它有多好。对吧。但你知道它有多烂。
That's something you can't run away from. That makes sense. Then conversely, was there ever, what was the thing that you thought, people will like this, but you were surprised at how well it resonated with people? I think, well, I did a production of The Crucible a long time ago with Liam Neeson
这是你无法否认的。这倒说得通。那反过来，有没有那么一次，你以为大家会喜欢，但它在人们心中引起了如此强烈的共鸣，这让你感到意外？我想，很久以前我和利亚姆·尼森（Liam Neeson）合作过一版《萨勒姆的女巫》（The Crucible），
that Arthur Miller was actually involved in. And before I accepted the job, I was offered Goody Proctor and I thought, oh for fuck's sake, who wants to do the crucible? Oh God, you buckle shoes and ye oldies speak. Oh, for God's sake. And I called my dad and I was like, I've been offered Goody Proctor and I don't know,
阿瑟·米勒（Arthur Miller）本人也参与其中。在我接受这份工作之前，剧组找我演古迪·普罗克特（Goody Proctor），当时我想：哦，见鬼的，谁想演《萨勒姆的女巫》啊？天哪，穿着搭扣鞋，满嘴老掉牙的台词。哦，看在上帝的份上。我给我爸打电话说：他们找我演古迪·普罗克特，我不知道，
I don't know if I'm, he was like, oh no. He was like, you do that, you must do that. He's like it is a great play. And it's only because we've all seen nine hour high school productions of that play that it's sort of, you know, it's badly represented. Not that it shouldn't be done there, it should, but you know, you don't realize how great that play is.
我不知道我能不能……他当时就说：哦，不。他说：你一定要接，你必须接下这个。他说这是一部伟大的戏剧。正因为我们所有人都看过那种演九个小时的高中版《萨勒姆的女巫》，所以它才变得有点，你知道的，被恶劣地呈现了。并不是说高中不该排演它，应该演，但你知道的，你根本意识不到那部戏有多么伟大。
And I had no idea what a masterpiece that thing was. A masterpiece. And then you had incredible audiences for a masterpiece that thing was. A masterpiece. And then you had incredible audiences for that, I'm sure, and that sort of, was that a bit of rocket fuel in your career as far as things that followed that? I mean, can you identify a particular job or moment where it felt different to you, like, oh, the next few years might be a little bit easier
我当时根本不知道那玩意儿是一部杰作。一部杰作。而且我敢肯定，为那部杰作捧场的观众也极为非凡，而且那种经历，这算不算是你职业生涯中的一把火箭助推器，为接下来的发展铺平了道路？我是说，你能指出具体是哪部作品或哪个时刻，让你觉得情况有所不同了，比如，哦，接下来的几年可能会比过去几年稍微容易一点。
than the last few. No, I've never been someone who feels a big boost from any one job. I really haven't. Wow. I think it's been very subtle and consistent, and I'll take that. Thank you for, I mean, that's fine by me.
不，我从来都不是那种会因为某一部作品而感到事业飞黄腾达的人。我真的没有。哇。我觉得一切都是那么潜移默化且稳扎稳打，我接受这样的节奏。谢谢你……我是说，这对我来说挺好的。
Just for me, just as an audience member, I would say you hit my radar significantly three separate times early on with Mystic River, Squid and the Whale, and you can count on me. Those were big, big moves for me, just as a fan. It's funny, because different people have different things. Some people, there's the Love Actually crowd, there's the Indie Movie crowd,
对我个人而言，作为一个观众，我想说你在早期有三次狠狠惊艳了我的雷达，分别是《神秘河》、《鱿鱼和鲸》和《你是可爱的》（You Can Count On Me）。作为粉丝，对我来说那是几部非常、非常重量级的作品。很有意思，因为不同的人有不同的记忆点。有些人对《真爱至上》情有独钟，有些人是独立电影的粉丝，
there's the Clint Eastwood crowd, there's the theater people, so it's always interesting, the John Adams people. I mean, you conquered it all. I know. Oh, well, hardly, but that's nice to think so. No, but when you hear those credits, you go like, holy shit, right?
有些人是克林特·伊斯特伍德的影迷，还有戏剧迷，所以总是很有趣，还有《约翰·亚当斯》的剧迷。我是说，你把各种题材都征服了。我知道。哦，哪里，其实谈不上，不过能这么想真是太好了。不，但当你听到那些代表作时，你会忍不住想：卧槽，对吧？
And they're so varied. I mean, we were talking about with JB a little bit before, and actually Sean too, if you think those credits, you go like, holy shit. Yeah. Right? And they're so varied. I mean, we're talking about with JB a little bit before, and actually Sean too, if you think about it, you did sitcom, you've done, you've won a Tony. I mean, these are to have so- Oh, I have not won a Tony. Oh no, but I mean-
而且它们跨度太大了。我是说，我们刚才跟JB稍微聊过，其实肖恩也是，如果你想想那些代表作，你会想：卧槽。对吧？而且它们跨度太大了。我是说，我们刚才跟JB稍微聊过，其实肖恩也是，如果你仔细想想，你演过情景喜剧，你演过……你还得过托尼奖。我是说，这些能拥有如此——哦，我没有得过托尼奖。哦不，但我的意思是——
No, but to do- No, no, no, no, Sean won the Tony. Sean did, no, no, without question, he won a Tony. Well, we should all have one. Yeah, yeah, in what was a very quiet, quiet year. But do you, but you did so many things that were, that worked on so many different levels.
不，但是去演——不，不，不，不，肖恩得过托尼奖。肖恩得过，对，毫无疑问，他得过托尼奖。好吧，我们其实都该得一个。对，对，是在一个非常冷清、竞争极小的年份。不过你——你确实做了很多事情，这些作品在很多不同的层面上都获得了成功。
I mean, you think about Ozark or You Can Count On Me, which I love, I mean, we love Kenny Lonergan. Yeah, was that your first nom, was that your first Oscar nom, You Can Count On Me? Yes, yes it was. I remember that, I remember singing it at home. I was so blown away, of course, everything before that, but that movie really had an impact on me,
我是说，想想《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）或者《你是可爱的》，我太喜欢了，我是说，我们都爱肯尼斯·洛纳根（Kenneth Lonergan）。对，那是你的第一次提名吗，你的第一个奥斯卡提名是《你是可爱的》吗？是的，是的，就是那次。我记得那个，我记得当时在家听到消息时的情景。我当时震惊呆了，当然，之前的每部作品也很棒，但那部电影确实对产生了深远的影响，
and you especially. I was just, that's when I first was like, oh my God, I gotta find out more about this person. And I just thought. You know, there was this, they did a 25 year fundraiser thing, and I don't like to watch myself, so as Jason knows. I know, I just don't get it.
尤其是你。我当时就想，那是第一次让我觉得：哦天哪，我得去好好了解一下这个人。我当时觉得。你知道，有一次他们搞了一个25周年的筹款活动，我不喜欢看自己演的戏，正如杰森所知。我知道，我就是看不下去。
Why would you treat yourself to it? Oh, please. So I went and saw the, I just don't get it. Why would you treat yourself to it? Oh, please. So I went and saw the, I went and watched it for the first time in 25 years. I think I've maybe only seen it once. And it was so wild. And Jason, I don't know if you feel this way when you look at stuff from a long time ago.
你怎么会愿意花时间折磨自己呢？哦，拜托。所以我去看了那个——我就是看不下去。你怎么会愿意花时间折磨自己呢？哦，拜托。所以我去看了那个——我25年来第一次看了它。我想我大概只看过那一次。那感觉太疯狂了。杰森，我不知道你回看自己很久以前的作品时是不是也有这种感觉。
But I saw things in myself. Well, I saw things in myself that don't exist anymore. They're parts of me that are just from another time. That because of age or where I was or the relationship I was in, or parents and dynamics, and all of that's gone. And then I could also see the things that I recognize
但我从自己身上看到了一些东西。嗯，我看到自己身上有些东西已经不复存在了。它们只是我生命中某个过去的片段。因为年龄、我当时身处的环境、恋情、或是父母和家庭的动态，所有这些都已经烟消云散了。然后我也能看到那些我还认得出来的
that is still there. So it was a wild thing to. Yeah, there are time capsules kind of of that moment in your life. We had Ruffalo on and he talked really lovingly about sort of, we got the role on You Can Count On Me and his collaboration with Kenneth Lonergan. Does it all still sit fondly for you?
依然存在的东西。所以这感觉真的很奇妙。对，那些就像是你人生某个时刻的时间胶囊。我们之前请来了马克·鲁法洛，他深情地谈到了我们在《我能凭 A 吗？》中获得角色，以及他与肯尼斯·罗纳根的合作。你对这一切现在回想起来都还是美好的感觉吗？
Was that as great as experience as it seemed like it was? It was a very tough shoot. You know, they had like two cents, so we were sitting outside, and then we had to clean out a, finally I was like, guys, we need a place to sit. Like, I can't sit outside. I can't change outside.
那段经历真的像看上去那么棒吗？那是一次非常艰难的拍摄。你知道，他们大概只有两分钱的预算，所以我们得坐在室外，然后我们还得清理出一个……最后我实在是忍不住说：“伙计们，我们需要一个能坐的地方。我不能坐在外面。我也不能在外面换衣服。”
Like, I need a place. And so, behind the house where we were filming, there was a chicken coop, that literally the chickens had left like two days prior. I mean, it was like, you know, chicken shit was like hanging in the cobwebs and I was like, perfect. So I went in, we cleaned it up and we all sat in the chicken coop.
我说：“我需要一个地方。”于是，在我们拍摄的房子后面，有一个鸡舍，鸡群 буквально 两天前刚刚搬走。我的意思是，鸡屎都挂在蜘蛛网上了，当时我就想：“太完美了。”于是我走了进去，我们把它打扫干净，然后我们全都在鸡舍里坐了下来。
Oh, that's great. You know, so it was very rough and tumble, but you know, it bonded us all for life. I mean, Mark is literally like my brother, and Kenny and I are still close, and all of us are sort of bonded, and that's the thing about what we get to do. The connections that you make, Jason Bateman,
哦，太棒了。所以说，过程虽然非常艰难粗糙，但这让我们所有人结下了生死之交。马克简直就像我的亲兄弟一样，我和肯尼现在也很亲近，我们所有人都像是一家人，这就是我们所做的事情的意义所在。你所建立的联系，杰森·贝特曼，
are deep and meaningful, and very, very significant in your life. And you do develop chosen family along the way. And it's really, it's one of the greatest things. Do you end up spending more time with people on set than you do your family at home? When you're working on something, it's 12 hours. Yeah, what else I'd love is Truman Show.
是如此深厚、有意义，对你的人生有着极其重大的影响。一路上，你确实会培养出自己选择的“家人”。真的，这是最美好的事情之一。你在片场和别人在一起的时间，是不是比在家陪家人还要多？当你投入一部作品时，那就是整整 12 小时。对，我更喜欢的是《楚门的世界》。
Let's not forget about Truman Show. Truman Show, you see, there you go. It just keeps going. There's another one, I know it goes on and on. But I like this idea, see, there you go. It just keeps going. There's another one, I know it's on and on. Primal fear. I like this idea, Laura, that you brought up about this, about it being sort of a different life and different parts of you that kind of go away.
我们可别忘了《楚门的世界》。《楚门的世界》，你看，就是这样。它一直延续下去。还有一部，我知道没完没了。但我喜欢这个想法，你看，就是这样。它一直延续下去。还有一部，我知道没完没了。《一级恐惧》。劳拉，我喜欢你刚才提到的这个观点，关于这仿佛是另一种人生，你身上不同的部分就这样渐渐消逝了。
I was talking about this recently with somebody. It's an interesting thing as you get older, when you start to recognize that. Oh yeah, when you literally have a history. Yeah. Like you have a history, you have different periods of your life that you've been through, not just one, not two, but many, and it is wild to think.
我最近刚和某个人聊过这个。随着你年纪越来越大，当你开始意识到这一点时，这真是一件很有趣的事。哦对，当你真的拥有了一段历史。对。就像你拥有过去，你经历过人生中的不同阶段，不止一个，也不是两个，而是很多个，想一想真的觉得很疯狂。
Yes, last night, Scotty and I went down a YouTube rabbit hole about opening songs to old shows from the 70s and 80s and 90s, and we did Silver Spoons, we looked up all your TV, all those Dukes of Hazzard, Fats of Life, Dallas, all that. God, I want your life. I'd really love to come back as you, Sean. I mean, this is how we film nights.
对，昨晚斯科蒂和我一直在 YouTube 上疯狂搜索 70、80 和 90 年代老节目的开场曲，我们看了《银匙小宝贝》，还搜了你演的所有电视，什么《正义前锋》、《不同的人生》、《达拉斯》，所有这些。天哪，我想要你的人生。我真的很想下辈子变成你，肖恩。我的意思是，我们晚上的节目就是这么拍的。
We go over. But I was watching these openings of these shows and it took me right back to being a kid. Like something clicks in your brain. Manics. Yeah. Barnaby Jones. Yes, all those.
我们接着说。但当我看着这些节目的开场时，一下子就把我带回了童年。就像你的大脑里有什么东西“咔哒”一声被触发了。曼尼克斯。对。巴纳比·琼斯。对，所有这些。
And I didn't, like the second I saw them, I actually had the feeling of a moment, like you said, of a stage in my life, which you don't sit around and think about until something triggers it. No. You know? All right, so now you've got, you know,
而且我没有……就在我看到它们的瞬间，我真的涌现出一种当时的情绪，就像你说的，是我人生某个阶段的情绪，平时你根本不会坐在那儿去想它，除非有什么东西触发了它。没错。你知道吗？好吧，那么现在你有……
will you tell these ding-dongs about this great super romantic story of you and Mark meeting each other in one of the most magical places in the world? And I just, she's got two incredible dudes in her life, her son and her husband. All right, you go ahead. So there you are.
你能不能跟这群笨蛋讲讲你和马克在世界上最神奇的地方之一相遇的那个超级浪漫的故事？瞧她，她生命中有两个了不起的男人，她的儿子和她的丈夫。好啦，你来吧。所以，事情就是这样。
Okay, so I've been very, very single for five years or so. And I'm invited to the Telluride Film Festival where there are two films screening there. And I think, oh, you know what? I've never taken my mother anywhere. I should take my mother to this. This will be good. I'm just gonna fly in, fly out, terrific.
好吧，我单身了大概有整整五年左右。然后我受邀参加特柳赖德电影节，那里有两部电影在放映。我想，哦，你知道吗？我从来没带我母亲去过任何地方。我应该带我母亲去这儿。这应该挺不错的。我打算飞过去，待完就飞走，太棒了。
So I bring my mother. The greatest. We go. And you know, sometimes you're paired with a liaison who's a little eccentric. Sometimes those people can be a little out there. And Mark sort of bounded up to us and said, hi, I'm Mark Schauer, I'll be taking care of you for the weekend.
所以我带上了我母亲。太棒了。我们去了。你知道，有时给你安排的联络人会有点古怪。有时那些人可能会有点特立独行。而马克有点像蹦蹦跳跳地向我们走来，说：“嗨，我是马克·肖尔，这个周末将由我来照顾你们。”
And I was like, oh, okay, like a nice person, okay. And we spent the weekend together, and I can remember we were waiting to go to a screening, and we were waiting for Bill Condon, my director, to come downstairs and join us so that we could leave. And I remember I turned my head and I looked at Mark, and I was like, am I attracted to this person? Am I attracted to my handler at the Telluride Film Festival?
当时我就想：“哦，好吧，就像个好人一样，行吧。”我们一起度过了那个周末。我记得当时我们正等着去参加一场放映，等我的导演比尔·康顿下楼来和我们会合，好让我们出发。我记得我转过头看着马克，心想：“我对这个人有感觉吗？我对特柳赖德电影节负责接待我的人有感觉吗？”
I was like, calm down. Like how wonderful I was feeling anything at all. I was like, you're good. He's got the title of handler. That's right. That's right. You know, yeah. And I thought, you know, I'm going to be gone in 24 hours.
当时我想：“冷静点。”能重新产生任何感觉是多么美妙的一件事啊。我就想：“你很安全。”他还有个头衔叫“接待员（handler）”。没错。没错。你知道，对。然后我想，反正24小时后我就要走了。
Just be happy you're still alive and get out. Get out of the house. And you know, alive and get out. Get out of class. And my mother was with me, so there wasn't a whole lot. Now, were you collaborating with her on this? Did you ask her what her take was? Oh, no, no, no. No, my mother, on the way to the airport, she was, well, Mark, are you involved with anyone?
只要庆幸自己还活着，然后离开就行。赶紧离开那个地方。而且我妈当时跟我在一起，所以也没什么机会。话说回来，在这件事上你妈跟你是一伙的吗？你问过她的看法吗？哦，没有，没有，没有。不，我妈在去机场的路上就问：“那个，马克，你有对象吗？”
At which point, I wanted to fall into the center of the Earth. No way. Center of the earth. And he was like, no, actually, I've been single for a bit. She was, oh, how interesting. So I left and we ended up, Mark and I ended up just emailing each other. I just thank you and I had a great time and we, emails sort of started to fly. And then he started to get a little nervous.
当时，我恨不得直接钻进地心。绝不可能。钻进地心。然后他说：“没，其实我单身有一段时间了。”我妈就说：“哦，真有意思。”于是我离开了，结果呢，我和马克开始互相发电子邮件。我只是发信感谢他，说我玩得很开心，然后……邮件就像雪片一样飞了起来。接着他开始有点紧张了。
He was like, I don't understand what's going on. And I immediately called, I said, look, I don't know what this is. I have no idea what this is. I don't know if we're friends, I don't know if it's more. The only thing I know is I don't want to let it go. So I don't know what to tell you. And he goes, well, when can we spend some time together?
他说：“我搞不懂这到底是怎么回事。”我马上打电话过去，我说：“听着，我不知道这算什么。我完全不知道这算什么。我不知道我们算不算朋友，我也不知道这算不算超越朋友。我唯一知道的是，我不想放手。所以我不知道该对你说什么。”他说：“那我们什么时候能一起待一会儿？”
And I said, well, I'm on a tour, a press tour when they used to do that. And he goes, well, where are you going to be together? And I said, well, I'm on a tour, a press tour when they used to do that. And he goes, well, where are you going to be? I said, I was going to be in Seattle, I was going to be in Chicago. He's like, I'm from Chicago. When are you in Chicago? Oh boy.
我说：“嗯，我在进行巡回宣传，就是以前那种宣传巡演。”他说：“那你接下来要去哪里？”我说：“嗯，我在进行巡回宣传，就是以前那种宣传巡演。”他说：“那你接下来要去哪里？”我说：“我要去西雅图，我要去芝加哥。”他说：“我是芝加哥人。你什么时候去芝加哥？”天哪。
And I was, well, this date. He goes, I'll meet you in Chicago. At which point I got very nervous and very scared and tried to get out of it several times. And I can remember going down the elevator in Chicago to meet him in the lobby, just terrified. Like, what am I doing? What in the world am I doing?
然后我说：“就这个日期。”他说：“我在芝加哥等你。”那一刻我变得非常紧张，非常害怕，好几次都想临阵脱逃。我记得我在芝加哥坐电梯下楼去大厅见他时，简直吓坏了。心想：“我在干什么？我到底在干什么？”
Having a date. Jesus God, someone I don't, what is happening? So at this point, you hadn't been on a date in quite some time? Yeah, no, no. So when you say you're scared, is that what you mean? You're like scared, like, I don't know how to do a date? I just, I didn't know if you, I don't know this guy.
居然要去约会。天啊上帝，一个我根本不认识的人，这到底是怎么回事？所以在这之前，你已经有很长一段时间没有约会过了？对，没有，没有。所以当你传说自己很害怕时，指的就是这个意思吗？你很害怕，比如，我不知道该怎么约会？我只是……我不知道该怎么面对，我不认识这家伙。
Is he a serial killer? Like what am I doing? I don't know anything about this guy. He's just flown across the country to come see you. Is that weird or is it flattering? What is happening? What is happening? And where did, did he live in Telluride at that time?
他是个连环杀手吗？我到底在干什么？我对这个人一无所知。他竟然为了见你大半个国家飞过来。这很奇怪还是让人觉得受宠若惊？这到底是怎么回事？这到底是怎么回事？当时他住在特柳赖德吗？
Yes, he drove a friend's car, which he had to drop off anyway. He was doing a favor for a friend, and he just made it work so that he could drive his car. How do you think you get rid of bodies? You put them in a car and you put it in a swamp. Sure, I know how to get rid of a body. And I got out of the elevator,
是的，他开着朋友的车，那辆车他本来也得开去还。他是在帮朋友一个忙，所以顺便把时间错开，好让他能开着车过去。你觉得该怎么处理尸体？你把它塞进车里，然后推进沼泽。没错，我知道怎么处理尸体。我走出电梯，
and I turned and I saw him there, and like every fear evaporated. Oh. And I was like, oh, this is going to be fine. Yeah. This is going to be okay. And that was true. It's not amazing how you can just read that
一转身看到他站在那里，所有的恐惧瞬间烟消云散。哦。当时我想：“哦，这下没事了。对。这下一切都会好起来的。”事实也确实如此。你不觉得你能从
in people's faces. Yeah, it was really, yeah. Like there's just a chemical sort of. There's like a vibe there, yeah. Yeah, like you just, you're like, oh, oh, okay. This was how many years ago? Oh my God, 18, 20, 2004. So almost 20 years ago, yeah.
人们的脸上看出这一点，真的很神奇吗？对，真的，对。就像有一种化学反应。就好像那里有一种磁场，对。对，就像你突然觉得……哦，哦，好吧。这已经是几年前的事了？哦天哪，18年、20年，2004年。所以差不多快20年前了，对。
Wow. Yeah. And how old is Bennett now? He's 10. Your son? 18, 20, 2004, so almost 20 years ago, yeah. Wow. And how old is Bennett now, your son? He's 10. He's 10. Oh my God. Isn't that wild? I know, so everybody go to film festivals,
哇。对。那本尼现在多大了？他10岁了。你的儿子？18年、20年，2004年，所以差不多快20年前了，对。哇。那本尼现在多大了，你的儿子？他10岁了。他10岁了。哦天哪。是不是很疯狂？我知道，所以大家快去电影节吧，
that's all I have to say. Tell you right is a magic place. It is, just go, go, go, go, go. That's a great, you know what, that's a really nice story. Yeah, you didn't have to do any swiping, nothing like that, although I hear swiping is very nice nowadays, I hear it's easy. Now, Bennett, showing any interest in doing what you do?
这就是我想说的。特柳赖德是个神奇的地方。确实是的，去吧，去吧，去吧，去吧。这真是一个……你知道吗，这是一个非常美好的故事。对，你不需要在手机上左划右划，虽然我听说现在左划右划挺好的，听说很简单。话说回来，本尼对做你这行表现出什么兴趣了吗？
No, absolutely not, and refuses to watch anything I've ever done. I mean, I made- My kid's the same one. I made Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles specifically for him. Because anything else would emotionally damage him and scar him for life. Did he see it?
不，完全没有，而且拒绝看我演过的任何东西。我的意思是，我拍过……我孩子也一样。我拍《忍者神龟》纯粹就是为了他。因为其他任何东西都会对他的心理造成创伤，给他留下终身阴影。他看了吗？
No, won't see it, refuses. Won't see it. What? Refuses. Does he explain what his problem is? Because my kids do. They're just like, it's just weird. You know?
没有，不看，拒绝看。不看。什么？拒绝看。他有没有解释过他有什么毛病？因为我的孩子们也是这样。他们就会说：“这感觉太诡异了。”你知道吗？
And they don't like when something bad happens to me. Like, they can't deal deal with any sort of pain or even any sort of challenge, like running from someone or something like that. A black rabbit, man. It's not gonna happen with you. Yeah, I'm not gonna like that. Oh, and I agree with you, Sean.
而且他们不喜欢我遭遇不好的事情。比如，他们无法接受任何形式的痛苦，甚至无法接受任何挑战，比如被什么人追杀之类的。黑兔子，哥们。你可不会遇到这种事。对，我可不会喜欢那样。哦，我同意你的看法，肖恩。
I've seen the pilot. Amazing. Amazing. She's done more than that. No, listen, I knew it was gonna be good, but I was floored by how great it was. And the thing that's great. Jimmy, tell us why.
我看过试播集了。太棒了。太棒了。她做到的可不止这些。不，听着，我知道这会很好，但它的精彩程度还是把我彻底震撼了。最棒的一点是……
Well, Laura, Laura. Well, hold on, hold on, hold on, no, no, no, no, I'm not that, I'm not that, I'm that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that. The thing that is amazing when you have a relationship with someone who you've worked with for a long period of time and you watch them grow, and to see Jason turn into this unbelievable director.
吉米，告诉我们为什么。好吧，劳拉，劳拉。等等，等等，等等，不，不，不，不，我不是那个……最棒的一点是，当你和共事了很长时间的人建立起一种关系，看着他们成长，看着杰森变成这样一个不可思议的导演……
I mean, always great, but this is a whole other level, and I've said this to him. I mean, it was absolutely, I was undone when I saw it. I was so proud of it. I agree, and I agree, and I want to say this too. I agree with you, and we mentioned it before, and I don't want to embarrass you, JB, but it's also very confusing to watch Somebody your friend somebody you love. Yeah grow while simultaneously they are shrinking. Yes that has been
我的意思是，他一直都很优秀，但这完全是另一个层面的事，我也对他这么说过。我的意思是，绝对是……我看到的时候整个人都惊呆了。我为此感到无比骄傲。我同意，我也同意，我还要说这一点。我同意你的看法，我们之前也提到过，我不想让你难堪，JB，但看着一个你认识的人、你深爱的人，在成长的同时又在不断“缩水”，这种感觉也挺让人困惑的。对，那简直是
total atrophy I'm playing a drug now. I saw I saw JB at the pool at his house two days ago I came over two days ago. I came over two days in a row. How'd you see him? And he was at, I drove over there. The light must have been hitting him directly. Yeah.
全面萎缩。我现在在演一个吸毒者。我看到……我两天前还在他家的泳池见到过 JB，我前天刚过去。我连续两天都去了。你怎么见到他的？他就在……我是开车过去的。当时光线一定直直地照在他身上。对。
Now speaking of directing, Laura came in heroically and agreed to direct episode three and episode four of Black Rabbit. I can't wait to see those, Laura. And she crushed this so hard. Not, she was. Look. We haven't seen it yet.
说到导演，劳拉挺身而出，英雄般地答应执导《黑兔子》的第三集和第四集。我等不及要看那些了，劳拉。而且她完成得太出色了。不是说她……听着。我们还没看过呢。
We don't know. No, no, no, no. I was there for every single day. And I've seen the dailies, I've seen the stills, et cetera, et cetera. But you know, I knew she was going to be an incredible leader on set as far as just like this culture of friendliness and kindness
我们还不知道。不，不，不，不。我每一天都在现场。我看过毛片（粗剪素材），看过剧照等等等等。但你知道，我知道她会成为片场一位不可思议的领导者，无论是营造那种友好、善良的文化氛围，
and support and all that stuff. Like the crew just freaking loved her, as did the cast. But her comfort with this added responsibility, like, is acting, not to belittle acting at all, but actors simply are kind of insulated from, you know, like almost three quarters of the process because things need to be decided on and set up and assets need to be put into motion and et cetera, then the actors come in and do their magical thing. She took on all of that, had only done it once before
还是支持大家之类的事情。剧组的人都爱死她了，演员们也是。但她对这种新增责任的适应能力……并不是说要贬低表演，但演员在很大程度上其实是被“隔离”在外的，比如大约四分之三的制作流程，因为很多事情需要决定、搭建，资产需要投入运作等等，然后演员们才进组发挥他们的魔力。她把这些全都扛了下来，而且在此之前她只做过一次，
on Ozark, directed one of our best episodes ever. And I, she was, her place is about three blocks from our studio and I said, hey, it's real close. It's not terrible stuff. There's a good crew, there's a good cast. We would love to have you. We please consider it. And it would have been so easy for her to say no.
就是在《黑钱胜地》里，执导了我们有史以来最好的一集之一。当时我的工作室离她家大约有三个街区，我说：“嘿，离得挺近的。也没那么糟糕。剧组很棒，演员也很棒。我们非常希望你能来。请考虑一下。”如果她当时拒绝，其实会轻松得多。
And so much free time if she said no. Let me ask you this. And you don't have to pat yourself on the back, but isn't it a gift to have been an actor and then a director? Without a doubt. And also, but I really, I can't emphasize enough how, I would never have done this unless Jason really pushed me
而且如果她拒绝了，就能拥有大把的空闲时间。让我问你这个。你不需要自我标榜，但既当过演员又当过导演，难道不是一种天赋吗？毫无疑问。而且，但是我也……我怎么强调都不为过，如果不是杰森 vraiment 极力推着我去做这件事，
to do it, ever. I had no desire to do it, none. Why? I would say, A, I didn't want to be one of those like idiot directors who you're saddled with, who didn't know what they were doing. I didn't want to be one of those people, you know, idiot directors who you're saddled with who didn't know what they were doing. I didn't want to be one of those people. You're looking at JB, why are you looking at him?
我绝对永远不会这么做，绝对不会。我一点这方面的欲望都没有，一点也没有。为什么？我会说，首先，我不想成为那种你不得不忍受的、根本不知道自己在干什么的白痴导演。我不想成为那种人，你知道的，那种你不得不忍受的、根本不知道自己在干什么的白痴导演。我才不想当那种人。你在看着 JB，为什么看着他？
Yeah, she's staring right at me. And then, and also I didn't want to jeopardize my relationship with Jason. Yeah. I mean, that's another thing. Yeah, but that horse left the barn on Ozark. He did such an incredible job on that episode. I know, but still, you know, it's,
对，她正死死盯着我呢。然后，还有就是我不想危及我和杰森的关系。对。我的意思是，这也是一方面。对，不过那匹马早就从《黑钱胜地》的马厩里跑出去了。他在那一集里的表现太不可我知道，但即便如此，你知道，这……
I don't think of myself as a director at all. I think of myself as an actress who's directed a few things now. But, you know, I don't know, as I've said to Jason, like, I don't know how to thank him for that. How do you thank someone for giving you a whole other sort of way to go? You do it all the time.
我一点也不把自己当成导演。我只把自己当作一个现在执导过几部作品的女演员。但是，你知道，正如我对杰森所说的那样，我不知道该怎么感谢他。你怎么去感谢一个为你打开了全新方向的人呢？你一直在这么做。
But what about, now do you, I'm going to get you, I've talked to you casually about this, now I'm going to get you, I've talked to you casually about this, now I'm going to get you on record. What part of your life going forward do you see directing being in? Like what's our ratio going forward? I mean, as you talked a little bit earlier about how the roles, you kind of implied this,
但是，接下来……你觉得呢？我之前跟你随便聊过这个，现在我要把你说的录下来。在你未来的生活中，你觉得导演工作会占据什么地位？比如我们未来的合作比例会是怎样？我的意思是，正如你刚才稍微聊到的那样，随着我们年龄增长，角色会变得越来越好，你暗示了这一点，
the roles get better and better the older we get, because they're more complicated, they're more nuanced, you're drawing on more from yourself. So acting I'm sure won't slow down, but there is time to do the directing as well. Did you get enough of a challenge and satisfaction from it to make it a bigger part of your life? You know, I think I will go with it
因为角色变得更复杂、更有细微差别，你可以从自己身上挖掘出更多东西。所以演戏肯定不会放慢脚步，但同时也有时间去搞导演工作。你从中学到了足够的挑战和满足感，让它成为你生活中更大的一部分吗？你知道，我想我会顺其自然，
the way I have gone with the other stuff, which is if it comes my way or if there's something I find or if there's something I wanna do, then I'll do it. But will you tell your people to look? I think they will look. Okay, all right. I think they're gonna look. Good.
就像我对其他事情的态度一样，如果有机会找上门来，或者我发现了什么项目，或者有什么我想做的事，那我就去做。但你会叫你的人去留意吗？我想他们会留意的。好吧，好吧。我想他们会去留意的。很好。
What has it done for you as an actor? How has directing this much now changed? Has it changed the way? It's not a lot. But yeah, but no, but do you think it's gonna change the way that you approach the work now, that you approach material, not to get into process, but just like when you're reading material, do you look through a different set of eyes a little bit?
作为一名演员，这给你带来了什么改变？现在执导了这么多作品，它是否改变了……这其实没多少。但是，对，不过，你觉得它会改变你现在对待工作的方式吗？你对待剧本的方式——不是说要深入探讨流程，而是当你在阅读剧本时，你看待事物的眼光是不是稍微有点不同了？
I, you know, I'll have to see because the Ozark, which I did was such a sort of a blip and sort of I was, my head was spinning the whole time and I just didn't know what had happened. And then this one was so intense in the best way and so all consuming. Literally we finished on Thursday.
我，你知道的，我还得看看，因为我拍的《黑钱胜地》就像是一个小插曲，我的脑袋当时转个不停，我都不知道发生了什么。然后这部剧非常激烈，是以最好的那种方式，让人全心投入。真的，我们周四刚杀青。
I just got out of bed this morning. I mean it took me like three days to, the fatigue is a whole other level of fatigue. Look how wiped out her dog still is. Exactly. You know, so, you know, so I'll be really curious to see what it does. Hopefully it will make me a better actress.
我今天早上才刚从床上起来。我是说我花了大约三天时间，那种疲惫是完全不同层面的疲惫。看看她的狗现在还累成什么样。完全是。所以，你知道的，所以我会很好奇它上映后的反响。希望它能让我成为一个更好的女演员。
I mean, that's the, that's the hope. Did it take more out of you than doing a one woman show? Eight shows a week? Absolutely. Are you kidding? Really? Absolutely. Oh, it did, really? I didn't have to deal with any people. I didn't have to deal with anybody. It was just me.
我是说，这就是，这就是希望。这比演一个人的独角戏还要耗费精力吗？一周八场演出？当然。你在开玩笑吗？真的吗？绝对的。哦，真的吗？我不用应付任何人。我不需要应付任何人。只有我自己。
I only had to deal with my own horrible stuff. But I didn't have to deal with 200 people. And 4,000 questions. Yeah. You don't have to reveal any names, any things. What's the thing that you find difficult in any working relationship? Something that gets you, first of all,
我只需要应付我那些糟糕的事情。但我不需要应付200个人。以及4000个问题。是的。你不需要透露任何名字，任何事情。你在任何工作关系中觉得困难的是什么？有什么事情首先
that you won't stand for, or second, that really kind of rubs you the wrong way and you look out for to avoid. Yeah, I think it's always hard when people have a preconceived notion of what something is supposed to be. And then you come and you see something very different, or you see something way beyond that.
是你无法容忍的，或者其次，真的很让你反感，你会注意并刻意避开的？是的，我觉得当人们对某事应该是什么样有着先入为主的观念时，总是很难处理。然后你来了，看到了非常不同的东西，或者看到了远超于此的东西。
And that is always a painful negotiation for everybody. And I understand from the other point of view like why that would be hard. I totally, totally get it. And we were very lucky on this one, how amazing all these writers were and all of that stuff. But I've seen that from the acting standpoint as well. I've really seen it more as an actress.
对每个人来说，这总是一个痛苦的妥协过程。而且我从另一个角度也能理解为什么这会很难。我完全、完全理解。我们在这部剧里非常幸运，这些编剧都太棒了，诸如此类的事情。但从表演的角度我也见过这种情况。我作为一个女演员真的见得更多。
Like people don't see what, I can just see things very clearly sometimes. And it's, I turn to these people and go, but you wrote this. I'm just doing what you wrote. Like whether you are aware of it or not, you wrote this. You know? So.
就像人们看不到，我有时能把事情看得很清楚。然后我转向这些人说：“但这可是你写的。”我只是在照你写的演。无论你是否有意识到，这就是你写的。你知道吗？所以。
Right, right, right. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Now you've been Jason's onscreen wife for many years. You were. Yes, lucky me. Lucky you. Yeah. What is it, what's something about Jason Bateman that people might not know?
对，对，对。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。你当了杰森多年的荧幕妻子。你是。是的，我真幸运。你真幸运。是的。关于杰森·贝特曼，有什么是人们可能不知道的？
Who you'd like to divorce him about? Yeah, well, no, it could be good and or bad. What would it be over? What is something that Jason does that's kind of unique that you've noticed about him, like a quirk? Here's one thing that I think why our friendship is so, you know, fulfilling for me at least, and why working is so fulfilling for me, at least, and why working is so good is that we work completely differently.
你恨不得跟他离婚的事？是的，嗯，不，这可以是好的或者坏的。会是因为什么事呢？杰森有什么比较独特的习惯，是你注意到的一些小怪癖？这里有一点，我觉得为什么我们的友谊对我来说如此，你知道的，充实，至少对我来说是这样，以及为什么工作对我来说如此充实，至少对我来说是这样，以及为什么工作效果这么好，是因为我们工作的方式完全不同。
Sure, yeah. I mean, we come from totally different cultures, completely different. And I love watching him work. It's just kind of amazing. And it can only, that sort of work can only happen, and now I believe as well, the directing is benefiting from this as well,
当然，是的。我是说，我们来自完全不同的文化，完全不同。我喜欢看他工作。这简直太神奇了。而且这种，这种工作方式只有在——现在我也相信，导演工作也能从中受益，
from someone who's been doing it as long as Jason's been doing it. I mean, it's in his bones in a way that it will never be with most people. He's just had the time with it. Well, he's only got bones left now. It's true. He needs several cheeseburgers.
从一个像杰森这样干了这么久的人身上受益。我是说，这已经融入他的骨子里了，这是大多数人永远无法企及的。他只是花够了时间在这上面。好吧，他现在身上只剩骨头了。真的。他需要几个芝士汉堡。
He's walking back and forth. No, it's really, it's quite something. But this is probably what would lead to our divorce. It's too much work. It's a workaholic. Amanda and's really, it's quite something. But this is probably what would lead to our divorce. It's too much work, it's a workaholic. Amanda and I talk about it all the time. Although she doesn't tell me not to, but she's just like, she's asking me this morning too,
他一直在走来走去。不，真的，这挺了不起的。但这可能就是导致我们离婚的原因。工作太多了。是个工作狂。阿曼达和我经常讨论这个。虽然她没有叫我别干，但她只是——她今天早上也问我，
we were talking about this other thing. She's like, well, is that, if you were to direct that, is that all consuming? I was like, it always is. It's always consuming. Yeah. You know? I know.
我们在谈论另一件事。她就问，如果，如果你要去导那个，那是不是会占据全部的时间？我就说，一直都是这样。总是全神贯注。是的。你知道吗？我懂。
But that's why we love it. Can we get Amanda on here at some point too, do you think? Yeah. Talk about a deal that's tough to make. We've got Laura, and then we're working our way into reality. We're working our way towards your real wife, into having Amanda on me, amazing.
但这就是我们热爱它的原因。你觉得我们什么时候也能请阿曼达来这里做客？是的。说到一笔很难谈成的交易。我们请到了劳拉，然后我们一步步接近现实。我们正朝着你的现实妻子努力，让阿曼达来上节目，太棒了。
I'm the stand-in. We'll go around the circle. Next one will be either your current partner will, or an ex, or something like that. Sean, you as well. We'll all take turns. It'll just be sort of just like a rotating blood bath. You know?
我是替补。我们按顺序来。下一个要么是你的现任伴侣，要么是前任，诸如此类的。肖恩，你也是。我们都轮流来。这简直就像是一场轮流进行的血洗。你知道吗？
Oh my God. Well you sort of test the waters with me. I'm sort of, you know. Yeah, yeah. You know, as close as you'll get at this point. Laura, what do you do to zone out after you've been working 14 hours and you're done directing something like that
噢天哪。好吧，你先拿我试水。我差不多是，你知道的。对，对。你知道的，这是你目前能找到的最接近的人了。劳拉，你连续工作了14小时，拍完类似这样的导演工作或者大型戏剧之后，你做什么来放空自己
or a big play or something? I go to bed. Yeah. You know, I mean, honestly, there, or a big play or something. I go to bed. Yeah. I mean, honestly, there's not a whole lot that happens. What are you going to do this week? You finished directing that show last week, and now this week is your recuperate. Are you going to yoga?
或者类似的大型戏剧？我睡觉。是的。你知道的，说实话，或者类似的大型戏剧？我睡觉。是的。我是说，老实说，没发生太多别的事。你这周打算做什么？你上周刚导完那部剧，现在这周是你的恢复期。你要去练瑜伽吗？
Are you going to Pilates? Are you going to the gym? No, I'm staring at a wall. You're staring at the wall. I'm going to stare at a wall. I'm going to be at a wall. Yeah. I'm going to be really quiet. Really quiet. Right, your quiet activity is reading,
你要去练普拉提吗？你要去健身房吗？不，我在盯着墙发呆。你在盯着墙发呆。我要盯着墙发呆。我要面对着墙。是的。我要保持极度的安静。非常安静。对，你安静的活动是读书，
watching bad reality TV. Occasionally, yes, guilty. You reading anything good right now? What are you reading right now, anything good? I just picked up, oh God, what's it called? I won't leave you, do not leave me. Ah, I forgot, brah brah brah. But I was reading vigorously until Black Rabbit happened.
看低俗的真人秀电视节目。偶尔会，是的，有点罪恶感。你现在在读什么好书吗？你现在在读什么，有什么好看的吗？我刚买了一本，噢天哪，叫什么来着？我不会离开你，不要离开我。啊，我忘了，吧啦吧啦吧啦。但我在精神抖擞地阅读，直到《黑兔》出现。
And then it all fell apart. And then you're going to start editing next week, right? Yeah, yeah. Yeah. But Tomorrow, Tomorrow, and Tomorrow is one of the things I read last year, which I just still am floored by. Really?
然后一切都泡汤了。然后你下周就要开始剪辑了，对吧？对，对。对。不过《明日，明日，又明日》是我去年读的书之一，我至今仍然为之倾倒。真的吗？
Tomorrow, Tomorrow, and Tomorrow, it's wonderful. Fiction? Wonderful fiction, yeah. Spectacular. It's wonderful. Fiction? I'll check that. Wonderful fiction, yeah. Huh. Spectacular, yeah. Is it a thriller? No, it's about three friends who make video games.
《明日，明日，又明日》，太棒了。小说？精彩的小说，是的。太精彩了。太棒了。小说？我去查查看。精彩的小说，是的。哈。太棒了，是的。这是惊悚小说吗？不，是关于三个制作电子游戏的朋友的故事。
It's a world I know nothing about, don't care about, and boy, this book is glorious. It's so beautiful. Wow, really? Tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow. It's just, it's beautiful. I'm going to read it. I don't know, Are the options available?
这是一个我一无所知、也毫不关心的世界，天哪，这本书太辉煌了。太美了。哇，真的吗？《明日，明日，又明日》。就是，太美了。我要去读读看。我不知道，还有库存吗？
I think they're already, I'm sure they're already taken. Also, the librarianist is really good. I've heard of that one. Patrick DeWitt. Yes, I've heard of that one. Very, very good. Yeah. So you can join my book club. I'll send you some recommendations.
我想它们已经，我敢肯定已经卖完了。还有，《图书管理员》真的很好。我听说过那本。帕特里克·德威特。是的，我听说过那本。非常，非常棒。是的。所以你可以加入我的读书俱乐部。我会发给你一些推荐。
I've just been reading this, I'm reading this biography, it's 20 years old, on de Kooning right now, that it's just absolutely fascinating. Oh yeah. On Bill de Kooning. What's that mean? Willem. On the painter, Willem de Kooning. Bill de Kooning right now, that is just absolutely fascinating. Oh yeah. What's that Willem? On the painter Willem De Kooning.
我最近一直在读这个，我正在读这本关于德库宁的传记，已经有20年历史了，现在读起来绝对引人入胜。哦，是的。关于威廉·德库宁。那是什么意思？威廉。关于画家威廉·德库宁。现在正读比尔·德库宁的传记，绝对引人入胜。哦，是的。什么，威廉？关于画家威廉·德库宁。
Bill De Kooning is incredible. There's Sylvia Plath biography that everybody loves. I'm going to write that down too. Laura, what about if you weren't an actor or director, what do you think you would do? You had to do. Not where you would have possibly hit a left fork instead of a right fork early on,
比尔·德库宁太不可思议了。还有每个人都喜欢的西尔维娅·普拉斯传记。我也要把这个记下来。劳拉，如果你不是演员或导演，你觉得自己会做什么？你必须做的工作。不是指你早年可能在某个分叉口选错了方向，
but like today, if you had to pick a different career, what do you think you're best suited for right now? Like would you write books? Would you teach at Juilliard? I think medicine. Medicine? Medicine? Yeah, I think medicine. Really? I love medicine too.
而是像今天，如果你必须选择另一种职业，你觉得你现在最适合做什么？比如你会写书吗？你会去茱莉亚学院教书吗？我觉得是医学。医学？医学？是的，我觉得是医学。真的吗？我也喜欢医学。
Like a doctor or something? Yeah, I think medicine. Really? I like medicine too. You're like a doctor or something? Yeah, I think so. Do you love medical stuff and like, I can't get enough of it. Yeah, no, I do. I like to know people's issues, how they got it, what the cure was. And I weirdly know things. Like, how do I know what a pericardium is?
比如当个医生什么的？是的，我觉得是医学。真的吗？我也喜欢医学。你就像个医生什么的？是的，我猜是吧。你是不是很喜欢医学方面的东西，而且，我简直对它爱不释手。是的，不，我确实喜欢。我喜欢了解别人的病情，他们是怎么得病的，治疗方法是什么。而且我很奇怪地懂一些东西。比如，我怎么会知道什么是心包？
Why do I know that? Mm-hmm. You know, so. But I could see you working with people in maybe medicine and maybe teaching, maybe doing something. You have such a, and I'm gonna say that, you have such a kind smile.
我怎么会知道这个？嗯嗯。你知道的，所以。但我觉得你可能会和人们一起工作，也许在医学领域，也许在教学领域，也许做点别的事情。你有这样一个——我要说的是，你有这样一个亲切的微笑。
Yeah. And you really do. Aw, Will. It's true. But she, you know, all the way through Ozark, every weekend almost, she would be flying off to give some sort, because of her show, The Big C, which was centered around cancer. Yes?
是的。你确实有。噢，威尔。确实如此。但她，你知道的，在整个《黑钱胜地》拍摄期间，几乎每个周末，她都会飞去进行某种演讲，因为她的剧《网诊》（The Big C），那是一部以癌症为中心的剧。是的？
Yes. She would give these speeches to, correct me, Laura, patients, doctors, medical institutions, recovery homes, et cetera. She'd just deliver these speeches about the will to live and the joy of life or how to deal with grief, et cetera. You'd write these things and you'd fly across the country
是的。她会向——纠正我，劳拉——患者、医生、医疗机构、康复中心等发表这些演讲。她只是发表关于生存意志和生活乐趣的演讲，或者如何应对悲伤等等。你会写下这些东西，然后飞越大半个中国——
with your weekends off to talk to these people and buoy them. I just, I didn't like Angel. I love that. Yeah, and I sort of use it also as a way for arts advocacy. You know, which is just to talk about the arts as much as I can, anywhere I can, as long as I can, because it's so important. Like Sean, she's not sitting at home making sloppy Joes
利用你的周末去和这些人交流，振奋他们的精神。我只是，我不喜欢天使。我喜欢这样。是的，我某种程度上也把它当作一种艺术倡导的方式。你知道的，就是尽可能多地谈论艺术，在任何地方，只要有机会就谈，因为这太重要了。就像肖恩，她可不是坐在家里做肉酱三明治
and figuring out what TV's theme track you're doing. Sean and Scottie say we're going to talk about farts advocacy, am I right? In these two words. But I just think it's like, you're going to cut lines upstairs after you're done with all this angel work. I don't know, where does it come from?
然后琢磨你在做什么电视主题曲。肖恩和斯科蒂说我们要讨论艺术倡导，我没说错吧？就这两个词。但我只是觉得，你在忙完所有这些天使般的公益工作后，还要上楼去删减台词。我不知道，这动力是从哪里来的？
Mom, dad? I don't know. I think I like people. I think I, you know, and I love the arts. I love the arts. I think, I think like more than just like a selfish thing, I think it's unbelievably important for culture and society. I couldn't agree more.
妈妈，爸爸？我不知道。我想我喜欢人。我想我，你知道的，我热爱艺术。我热爱艺术。我觉得，我觉得这不仅仅是一件自私的事情，我认为它对文化和社会的意义简直重大得难以置信。我不能同意更多了。
I couldn't, it is so undervalued. It's unbelievably medicinal. You cannot, there is no wasted time when you're engaged with the arts. It will make everything better. I mean, it's just. I so agree. At a time when the brain is growing too.
我不能，这太被低估了。它具有难以置信的药用价值。你不可能，当你沉浸在艺术中时，没有一分钟是浪费的。它会让一切变得更好。我是说，就是这样。我太赞同了。这也是在大脑发育的时期。
So like with the work that you do at Juilliard too, and kids, I mean, they're not toddlers anymore. They're young adults. But I imagine that work for you is super fulfilling. Remind me what your role is currently there at Juilliard. What do you do there? What do you do? Tell Tracy in Wisconsin what you're doing there at Juilliard
所以，就像你在茱莉亚学院所做的工作，还有那些孩子们，我的意思是，他们不再是幼儿了。他们是年轻人。但我可以想象，这份工作对你来说非常有成就感。提醒我一下，你目前在茱莉亚学院的角色是什么？你在那里做什么？你做什么？告诉威斯康星州的特蕾西你在茱莉亚学院做什么，
and what Juilliard is for Tracy. Juilliard is a arts conservatory school, which is sort of one of the leading schools in the country that teaches music, opera, dance, and drama. There are four departments. At Lincoln Center? Right across the street from Lincoln Center is the Juilliard School, it's there.
以及茱莉亚学院对特蕾西来说意味着什么。茱莉亚学院是一所艺术表演艺术学校，可以说是全国领先的学校之一，教授音乐、歌剧、舞蹈和戏剧。有四个系。在林肯中心？就在林肯中心街对面，茱莉亚学院就在那儿。
It has a long, illustrious history. I somehow, by the grace of God, got in there, and people will ask, what was your big break? And for me, it was getting into that school, hands down. Hands down. So I was there into that school, hands down. Hands down. So I was there for four years, and about 15 to 18 years ago,
它有着悠久而辉煌的历史。不知怎么的，托上帝的福，我考进去了，人们会问，你的重大突破是什么？对我来说，那就是考进那所学校，毫无疑问。毫无疑问。所以我那四年都在那儿，大约15到18年前，
they called and asked me to give the commencement speech, which I did, and they also invited me to join the board of the school, which I did. I was the only, I think there were only two artists on the board at that time, and I've been on it now for a long time, and I'm now vice chair for a limited period of time. So I'm very involved there and seeing what institutions
他们打电话邀请我去发表毕业典礼演讲，我去了，他们还邀请我加入学校的董事会，我也加入了。我是当时董事会中唯一的，我想当时只有两位艺术家，我现在已经在里面待了很长时间，现在我是副主席，任期有限。所以我对那里非常投入，也看到了像茱莉亚学院这样的机构，
like Juilliard, what they do, how they do it, why they do it, and the challenges that are facing young artists today. And also I try to, when I have the time, I try to mentor the outgoing class. I will go in and talk to students, I'll take them out to lunch, and sometimes I can do it and sometimes I can't.
它们在做什么，它们是如何做的，它们为什么这么做，以及当今年轻艺术家所面临的挑战。而且我也尽量在有时间的时候，指导即将毕业的班级。我会去和学生们交谈，带他们去吃午饭，有时我能做到，有时做不到。
What is the biggest challenge, Laura, for a young aspiring actress today? What do you think that biggest challenge is? Money. Money. Right. I mean, it's impossible. I mean, and which is why Juilliard's making
劳拉，如今年轻的有抱负的女演员面临的最大挑战是什么？你觉得最大的挑战是什么？钱。钱。对。我是说，这太不可能了。我是说，这也是为什么茱莉亚学院在
such a concerted effort to go tuition free. You know, and why a lot of schools are, because we train these artists at this very, very high level. They leave and then they can't support themselves and then they drop out and we lose them. Right. Do you spend a lot of time raising money or working with people or working with groups
努力争取实行免学费的原因。你知道的，这也是为什么很多学校都在这么做，因为我们在极高水平上培养这些艺术家。他们毕业了，然后无法养活自己，接着就退学了，然后我们就失去了他们。对。你花很多时间筹集资金，或者与人合作，或者与团体合作
to try to raise money for the school? Are you guys dealing with high net worth individuals? All these people that you need, these patrons as it were, who some of them, I'm sure some of that's tough, but you need that, right? You need to have these people in order to keep it running. Yes, the angel people, yes. And then you need the small donations as well.
来为学校筹集资金吗？你们在和高净值个人打交道吗？所有这些你需要的人，这些赞助人，其中一些人——我确信其中有些很难对付，但你需要这个，对吧？你需要这些人来维持它的运转。是的，那些天使般的人，是的。然后你也需要小额捐款。
You need people just involved. You need people who just to care about the arts. Open your pocketbook for once. For fuck's sake. No, Jason. I just did a whole new winter wardrobe. It's thin right now. No, no, no, listen.
你需要有人参与。你需要关心艺术的人。难得大方一次，掏掏腰包吧。看在上帝的份上。不，杰森。我刚买了一整套新的冬季服装。现在手头很紧。不，不，不，听着。
Okay. He lost a lot of weight. He needs a new clothes. He just got back from Paris. He goes. Speaking of books and stuff, tell me something you've seen that you love recently. TV show, movie.
好吧。他减了很多肥。他需要新衣服。他刚从巴黎回来。他说。说到书之类的话题，告诉我一些你最近看到并非常喜欢的作品。电视剧，电影。
Before we leave the Juilliard thing, and speaking of angel people, so Laura just continues to blow my mind. So we have this young actor on the show, his name is Robert Elijah Coleman. He was going to Juilliard, he got cast in this show, he was working on a day, this is a month ago, when Juilliard graduation was happening.
在我们离开茱莉亚学院的话题之前，说到那些天使般的人，劳拉简直一次次让我大开眼界。我们在剧组里有一个年轻演员，名叫罗伯特·伊莱贾·科尔曼。他以前在茱莉亚学院上学，他被选入了这部剧，在一个工作日——这是一个月前——刚好赶上茱莉亚学院的毕业典礼。
He had done his four years at Juilliard, it's incredible to graduate from Juilliard, but he was scheduled to work on that day. Partly my fault, I was directing, but Laura was prepping her episodes coming in, so she was around the set. And what she decided to do as a big shot at Juilliard was to grab his diploma, grab his cap and gown, grab his diploma, grab his cap and gown,
他在茱莉亚学院度过了四年，能从茱莉亚学院毕业是令人难以置信的，但他那天被安排有拍摄工作。部分是我的错，我在导演，但劳拉当时在为她即将开拍的剧集做准备，所以她一直在片场。她决定作为一个茱莉亚学院的大人物做的事情是，去拿他的毕业证书，拿他的学士帽和学位服，去拿他的毕业证书，拿他的学士帽和学位服，
write this long speech, an incredible speech that one would receive if they were lucky enough to be at their ceremony when they're graduating, but he couldn't because he had to be sitting on set. She asked me if she could stop production for about five or 10 minutes, bring in a cake, do the whole thing, gather the whole crew, and she delivered the speech, and she put on the graduation music and everything.
写了一篇很长的演讲稿，一份如果足够幸运能在毕业典礼上亲自出席时才会收到的令人难以置信的演讲稿，但他不能去，因为他必须坐在片场。她问我是否可以暂停制作大约五到十分钟，拿一个蛋糕，搞一个仪式，把整个剧组聚在一起，然后她发表了演讲，还播放了毕业典礼的音乐以及所有这一切。
This kid, the greatest guy, was so bowled over as was the whole crew and cast and she presented him with his diploma and full graduation ceremony right there on set after four years of Juilliard. Like it was, it's like who has that idea? You know? That is really, really, really sweet. That is incredible. You know, it's a, there has that idea? Amazing. That is really, really, really sweet. That is incredible.
这个孩子，最棒的家伙，感到非常震惊，剧组和演员们也全都是这样，她直接在片场、在经历了四年朱莉亚学院的学习之后，为他颁发了毕业证并举办了完整的毕业典礼。就好像，这就像是谁能想出这样的主意？你知道吗？这真的是，非常、非常、非常贴心。这太不可思议了。你知道，这是一种，谁能想出这样的主意？太棒了。这真的是，非常、非常、非常贴心。这太不可思议了。
Well, you know, there are moments in your life, there are big moments that need to be recognized. And you know, Eli had been through, I know what it is to go through Juilliard. I know what it is to graduate from that school, to feel like you've done something, and now, oh God, what's gonna happen now? And you've done it with an ensemble of people,
好吧，你知道，你生命中总会有一些时刻，有一些重大时刻需要被认可。而且你知道，伊莱经历过——我知道经历朱莉亚学院是怎样的感受。我知道从那所学校毕业是怎样的感受，那种觉得你完成了某件事，然后，天哪，接下来会发生什么呢？而且你是和一群人一起完成的，
and it killed me that he was not gonna be with his class. And he didn't tell anybody on set. He did not mention it to anybody that he was missing his graduation. I knew, so I went to him, I'm like, are you okay about this? And he was so good-natured about it. He was so happy to be there.
而他不能和自己的班级在一起，这让我难受极了。而且他在片场没有告诉任何人。他没有向任何人提起他错过了毕业典礼。我知道这件事，所以我去找他，我说，你对这件事还好吗？而他对此表现得非常随和。他能在那里感到非常高兴。
He was like, I'm fine, I'm fine. And I just sort of couldn't stand it. So I, and Jason was kind enough to let me sort of hijack the set for a bit. So it was fun, it was really fun. The performance of being at a graduation doesn't come close to doing the thing that you graduated for.
他说，我很好，我很好。我只是觉得有点看不下去了。所以，杰森也很善良，让我稍微“劫持”了一下片场。所以很有趣，真的非常有趣。参加毕业典礼的这种形式，远远比不上真正去做你为此毕业的事情。
To get the job. Yeah, that's right. Right, and it didn't matter that they had to move that day, that he had to shoot that day because Jason had a golf game on the other day. That doesn't even matter, it doesn't even come up. It doesn't even come up. We'll work it out.
去获得那份工作。对，没错。没错，而且那天他们必须搬迁、他那天必须拍戏也根本无所谓，因为杰森另一天有高尔夫球局。这根本不重要，这甚至都不会被提及。这甚至都不会被提及。我们会搞定的。
That doesn't even come up. Yeah. Because he's got a team time with his buddies. Now Sean, what was your question that was a good one? I'm just going to see, I'm always interested in what people are watching recently that you liked or any recommendations, documentaries, movies. Alone.
这甚至都不会被提及。没错。因为他要和他的死党们去打高尔夫了。肖恩，你刚才那个好问题是什么来着？我只是想看看，我总是对人们最近在看什么、你们喜欢什么，或者有什么推荐、纪录片、电影感兴趣。《独行侠》。
Alone. I've been watching Alone. Me too. Jason loves that. I love Alone. Can I just say one more thing I want to talk about Alone. Before we get out of the Juilliard stuff, what can people do to support the arts wherever they live? Wherever anybody is, what would be a really important thing
《独行侠》。我一直在看《独行侠》。我也是。杰森很喜欢那个。我超爱《独行侠》。我能再多说一件事吗，我想聊聊《独行侠》。在我们结束朱莉亚学院的话题之前，人们可以做些什么来支持他们所在地方的艺术？无论任何人身在何处，最重要的事情会是什么
that people who listen to our podcast could do to try to help young people get involved in the arts? What can they do in there? Oh, I know, vote for the Democratic ticket. There's that. Well, apart from that. What could people do, honestly, Laura? Go. I mean, I think Sean.
听我们播客的人可以做些什么来试图帮助年轻人接触艺术？他们在那里能做什么？哦，我知道，投票给民主党。还有那个。嗯，除此之外呢。说真的，劳拉，人们能做些什么？说吧。我是说，我觉得肖恩。
I just thought that was a really good suggestion. Sean's got that update on his iOS where he does double thumbs up, it's fireworks. You know, I think it's go. Find something in your community that is there, go with your family, have a communal experience, and go. Get off your phone. And see what happens.
我只是觉得那真的是个好建议。肖恩在他的iOS系统上有那个功能，就是双击点赞会出烟花。你知道，我觉得就是去。在你的社区里找一个现成的东西，和你的家人一起去，去体验一种集体的生活，然后去。放下你的手机。看看会发生什么。
Here's a big name dropping moment, but Edward Albee said to me one time, he was, I know. Pick it up. but Edward Albee said to me one time, he was, I know. He said, listen to Bach for 10 minutes every morning. He says, it organizes the mind. And he's right. And so I tell people, when I give these speeches around the country, I tell people, try it for two weeks, see what happens.
这是一个很大的名流大招时刻，但爱德华·阿尔比曾对我说过一次，他当时是，我知道。接着说。但爱德华·阿尔比曾对我说过一次，他当时是，我知道。他说，每天早晨听十分钟巴赫。他说，这能整理思绪。他是对的。所以我告诉人们，当我在全国各地做这些演讲时，我告诉人们，试试两周，看看会发生什么。
Just 10 minutes. And Jason, you know, because you love classical music. You know, that it does, just 10 minutes. And Jason, you know, because you love classical music, you know, that it does, it permeates your being and it realigns you in a way, music does, I mean, Sean, you know this as well. You know, it's a powerful thing, the arts. And I think it's the most underused resource we have,
就十分钟。杰森，你知道的，因为你喜欢古典音乐。你知道它确实，只需十分钟。杰森，你知道的，因为你喜欢古典音乐，你知道它确实，它会渗透到你的生命中，以某种方式重新调整你，音乐就是这样，我是说，肖恩，你也很清楚这一点。你知道，艺术是一股强大的力量。而且我认为这是我们拥有的最未被充分利用的资源，
or one of them, in this country. And it makes me crazy that our government has never really leaned into that. Except now our surgeon general is using it for mental health. He's encouraging people to get involved in that. Yeah, I was gonna say, there's probably a lot less violence in the world.
或者其中之一，在这个国家。这让我抓狂的是，我们的政府从来没有真正倾心于此。除了现在我们的外科医生总监正在将其用于心理健康。他正鼓励人们参与其中。对，我正想说，世界上可能会少很多暴力。
I know that's a crazy thing to say. It's not. But if more people are exposed to the arts, there's a- Absolutely. And graduation rates just skyrocket if a kid is exposed to the arts, there's a... Absolutely. And graduation rates just skyrocket if a kid is involved in the arts. It's just skyrockets. And there's always something somewhere,
我知道这样说很疯狂。其实并不疯狂。但如果更多的人接触到艺术，就会有——绝对的。如果一个孩子接触到艺术，毕业率就会直线飙升，就会有——绝对的。如果一个孩子参与到艺术中，毕业率就会直线飙升。就是会直线飙升。而且到处都有这样的东西，
and you don't have to be good at it. You don't have to be an artist yourself. You have to be exposed to it. Willie's talking about starting to paint. He's going to start painting a bit. I can do stick figures. I mean, that's way beyond. We're not expecting more than that from Willie. It's not going to be... I'm not going can do stick figures. I mean, that's way beyond. We're not expecting more than that from Will.
而且你不需要在这方面很厉害。你自己不需要成为艺术家。你只需要接触到它。威利在说他要开始画画了。他要开始画一点画。我能画火柴人。我是说，那已经远远超出了。我们对威利没有更高的期望了。不会是——我不会能画火柴人。我是说，那已经远远超出了。我们对威尔没有更高的期望了。
It's not gonna be, I'm not gonna be showing anything. It's gonna be. Yes, yes you will. For this Christmas, that's all I want from you. It's a shitty painting. And I want it framed. It's gonna be really shitty. I'm excited about it.
不会是，我不会展示任何东西。将会是。会的，你会的。今年圣诞节，这就是我从你那里唯一想要的东西。那是一幅烂透了的画。而且我希望它被裱起来。那一定会非常烂。我很期待。
I was just thinking about it this morning, actually. Good. I can't wait to see some of that. But I think it's like, grab someone you love, or grab someone you like and go and have an experience and just see what happens. I grabbed somebody I liked at the stop and shop, but I didn't know them.
其实我今天早上刚想到这个。很好。我等不及要看其中的一些了。但我觉得就像是，抓住你爱的人，或者抓住你喜欢的人，去体验一下，然后看看会发生什么。我在全食超市（Stop & Shop）抓住了一个我喜欢的人，但我并不认识他们。
You're going to find out what happens when this case is adjudicated. Check out the Daily Mail. Wait, so let's get to, you were talking about Alone. You love Alone, like JB and me. Yeah, brand new season just started. I watched it because of him as well. Yeah, yeah.
你会发现当这个案件宣判时会发生什么。去看看《每日邮报》吧。等等，言归正传，你刚才在聊《独行侠》。你超级喜欢《独行侠》，就像JB和我一样。对，全新一季刚开始。我也是因为他才看的。对，对。
I know, it's intense, isn't it? I love the guys who go in, this is early, first few seasons, the really tough guys who are absolutely going to crush it, and they're gone in two hours. Yeah, I know. First ones out. You hear like a rustle in the waves,
我懂，这很紧张刺激，对吧？我喜欢那些刚进去的人，这是早期，头几季里，那些绝对能大展身手、极其硬核的家伙，结果两小时内就退出了。对，我懂。第一批被淘汰的。你听到波涛中有什么沙沙声，
and they're like, I'm tapping out, I'm tapping out, I'm tapping out. And I think that would be me. Yeah. I wouldn't last for two seconds out there. I'd tap out before they land the heli- Yes. Celebrity alone would be hilarious.
然后他们就说，我受够了，我退出了，我退出了，我退出了。我觉得那肯定是我。对。我在那里面撑不到两秒钟。直升机还没降落我就退出了——“名人独行”一定会超级搞笑。
I'd be tapping out when I'm connecting flights in Minneapolis. I'd be like- I would hang up on my manager on the phone call about the request. The great Aline Kashishian would get the hang up. That's right. I love the places they build for themselves.
我在明尼阿波利斯转机时就会退出了。我会像——我会直接挂断经纪人打来询问请求的电话。伟大的阿琳·卡希什扬（Aline Kashishian）会被挂电话。没错。我喜欢他们为自己搭建的那些住所。
Yeah. You know, those huts and the, it's just sort of, it's an amazing thing. It's like they took Naked and Afraid and kind of just heightened it a little bit. Yeah, yeah. And I also love these poor people filming themselves at the same time.
对。你知道，那些棚屋还有，这简直就是一种神奇的体验。就像他们把《原始生活21天》（Naked and Afraid）拿来，稍微升级了一下。对，对。而且我也很喜欢这些可怜的人同时还得自己拍摄自己。
I know, that's all part of it. I like it when they build a great house. There was a guy once in one of those seasons up in The Northwest Territories in Canada, and he built like this stone house with moss and stuff you like Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Moss was so and then they got it. They got to rip it down when they leave You know, they do that little time-lapse thing when it all goes away. It's like no Laura we're over we're over time. You will be compensated. Look checks in like no. Laura, we're over. We're over time.
我知道，这也是其中的一部分。我喜欢他们建一栋好房子的桥段。有一季里曾有个家伙，在加拿大西北地区，他用石头和苔藓之类的东西建了一座石屋，你肯定喜欢 对，对，对，对 苔藓是那么的然后他们必须把它拆掉当他们离开时你知道，他们做了那个所有东西都消失的小延时摄影，就像不，劳拉，我们超时了，我们超时了。你会得到补偿的。支票在——不。劳拉，我们超时了。我们超时了。
You will be compensated. Check's in the mail. We love you. I love you most. Yeah, I'm a massive, massive fan. Have always been. Truly. You know, I love all three of you.
你会得到补偿的。支票在路上了。我们爱妳。我最爱妳。对，我是个超级、超级大的粉丝。一直都是。真的。你知道，你们三个我都爱。
And you know, I've been lucky enough to work with two of you and Sean, we're due. Yeah, that's right. I would love it. So, figure that out. And thanks JB. Thanks for everything. I love you, I'll see you in a few days.
而且你知道，我有幸和你们其中的两个合作过，肖恩，该轮到我们了。对，没错。我很乐意。所以，把这事敲定吧。谢谢JB。谢谢你所做的一切。我爱你们，过几天见。
Say hi to Mark and Bennett. I sure will. And go feed your dog. Love the family, will do. I'm going to wake him up. Okay, bye. Bye Laura. Thank you, bye.
替我向马克和贝内特问好。我一定会的。去喂你的狗吧。代我向家人问好，我会的。我要去叫醒他。好的，再见。再见，劳拉。谢谢，再见。
Well that was lovely, it was painful for me. That was a lot of love to receive. I'm not good at that, but thank you. But you're doing better, you're doing better. She's, you know, I love, if you could pick a second wife, she would be it. Well imagine if it wasn't her. I mean, it was her for a reason, you know?
好吧，那真是太美妙了，对我来说却是个折磨。要接受那么多的爱。我不擅长这个，但谢谢你们。但你现在表现得越来越好了，越来越好了。她——你知道，我喜欢，如果你能挑选第二个妻子，那绝对就是她了。想象一下如果不是她。我的意思是，她来演是有原因的，你知道吗？
You guys really connected, and I can't imagine anybody else playing that part. I still remember the day I, she was the first person I went to on Ozark. I took her out to breakfast at this restaurant in the bottom of this hotel I was staying in in New York. It was there scouting, I think.
你们真的很有默契，我无法想象还有谁能演那个角色。我还记得那天我，她是《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）里我最先接触的人。我带她去我在纽约住的那家酒店楼下的那家餐厅吃早餐。当时我在那里勘景，我想是的。
And we share a manager, Alink Yashishian, and I said to Alina, I said, do you think Laura would ever consider doing a show again? and she's like we should just talk to her just you know, and I met her at that restaurant and just pitched her for an hour and a half and Was really nervous about even the possibility of her saying Yes, or no I just was such a big swing because I knew by having her on the show, not only would she be an incredible actor on it,
我们共用一个经纪人阿琳·卡希什扬，我对阿琳说，我问，你觉得劳拉会考虑再次出演电视剧吗？她说我们应该跟她谈谈，你知道的，然后我在那家餐厅见到了她，向她推销了一个半小时，对于她会说“好”或“不”的可能性，我当时真的感到非常紧张，因为这真的是一次豪赌，因为我知道只要有她加入这部剧，不仅她在剧中会是一个不可思议的演员，
but what she would sort of signal to the audience and to the community in the business about what the show is and what the show isn't. Like she's just such a great recruiter of high quality people and a declaration of sort of the quality we're kind of shooting for. And it was just such a gift that she said yes. The show would never would have happened without her, ever.
而且她会对观众、对业内社区传递出关于这部剧是什么、这部剧不是什么的某种信号。就像她真的是个招募高品质人才的高手，也是对我们所追求的那种剧集质量的一种宣示。她答应出演简直是天大的恩赐。如果没有她，这部剧根本就不可能拍成，绝对不可能。
I mean, I can't imagine anybody else doing that part. Yeah, yeah, so lucky. And what a great guest. Yeah, I've always been such a massive fan. Like she's an actor's actor. And she really is. Exactly. And you look at her body image,
我是说，我无法想象还有谁能演那个角色。对，对，太幸运了。而且真是个绝佳的嘉宾。对，我一直是她超级大的粉丝。她真的是演员中的演员。她确实是。没错。你看她的作品表，
it just goes on and on and on and on and on IMDB. It's crazy. I love that she was here. And by the way, long time coming. Yes, exactly. Yeah, that was, I mean, I remember talking to her. When we first got started, we were still doing Ozark. Right?
在IMDB上简直没完没了、没完没了、没完没了。太疯狂了。我很高兴她今天能来。顺便说一句，这是蓄谋已久了。是的，完全正确。对，那是，我记得跟她聊过。当我们刚开始的时候，我们还在拍《黑钱胜地》。对吧？
Yeah. Yeah, right at the end. Oh, that's right. Yeah, during COVID. I mean, for a year. Right. Yeah, I remember talking to her. At least.
对。对，就在尾声的时候。哦，对。对，在疫情期间。我是说，持续了一年。没错。对，我记得跟她聊过。至少。
Yeah. Yeah, I remember her sort of just looking at me like, I could just sense she was kind of looking at me like, you're doing what? Every week you're what? Yeah. Exactly. And then, yeah And then she started to say, well you know some people are talking to me
对。对，我记得她看着我的那种眼神，我能感觉到她那种眼神的意思，好像在说：你在干什么？你每周都在干什么？对。没错。然后，对 然后她开始说，嗯，你知道有些人跟我提起过
that apparently they've listened to your podcast or something, people are liking it. I'm like, you gotta come on, you gotta come on. And she was like, yeah. Well I was, it was nice to know, here we go. It was nice to know that somebody. Oh now you're just telling us. This is a guy who when you merge on a group.
说他们显然听了你们的播客什么的，人们很喜欢。我说，你一定要来上节目，你一定要来。然后她说，好吧。嗯，我当时，很高兴知道，我们开始吧。很高兴知道有人。哦，现在你开始教训我们了。这是一个在汇入车流时——
Nice of her to drop by or something like that. Is that what it was gonna be? You know, Shawn is just a terrible merger on the freeway. He actually comes in doing 120 miles an hour or doing 30 miles an hour and everyone's gotta slam on the brakes. Go ahead, zip her in. No, I just thought it's nice that she said hi to directing,
很高兴她能顺道过来或者类似的话。是这个意思吗？你知道的，肖恩在高速公路上汇入车流时简直烂透了。他开车时要么以每小时120英里的速度冲进来，要么以每小时30英里的速度慢吞吞，搞得所有人都得急踩刹车。继续吧，加塞进去。不，我只是觉得她能对导演说再见挺好的，
but she definitely didn't say, bye to acting. Christ. directing but she definitely didn't say acting oh fuck fucking fuck dude holy shit that is rough we might have to put you on a hiatus you can initiate bi-a-tus on a hiatus that you can initiate from. On a biatus. Biatus.
但她绝对没有对演戏说再见。天哪。导演，但她绝对没有对演戏说再——哦，操，他妈的操，老兄，天哪，这也太粗鲁了，我们可能得让你进入停工期了，你可以发起一个——你可以在一个停工期发起停工期。处于停工期。停工期。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
太机智了。更少。太机智了。更少。太机智了。更少。太机智了。更少。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太机智了。更少。太机智了。更少。太机智了。更少。太机智了。由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿尔马夫（Rob Armjarf）以及贝内特·巴比科（Bennett Barbico）手工精心制作。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。